and what may be one of the darkest
conspiracies ever exposed by the news
media in this country
the my pillow guy was seen meeting with
donald trump
in his hand notes which read they zoomed
in and it was something about
insurrection act it's hard to read
but of course the news is already coming
out saying that he was pushing for
martial law in his meeting with trump i
hope you realize that was joking about
that
it's not a dark conspiracy the my pillow
guy mike lindell had a meeting with
trump
he's saying he was just relaying
information it was a legal conversation
but the media some journalist took a a a
photo
of his notes and zoomed in you have no
idea what the papers are about but
there's mentions of insurrection act and
and
sydney powell and things like that so of
course instead of actually doing any leg
work
the media just says he's pushing for
martial law you combine that with the
story that's been freaking everybody out
the 20 000 fully decked out national
guard in dc
we're talking like live ammo shoot to
kill
really crazy stuff and people start
well they start going nuts that's why
it's i'm i just rag on the media so much
man
it is so irresponsible to come out and
say we saw a few words from far away on
a piece of paper
and now we know what it means when
you've got people who already believe a
ton of crazy conspiracies i don't care
from left to right
and you've got a major security event
happening this is ridiculously
irresponsible now as for what's really
going to happen on the 20th my opinion
joe biden's gonna be inaugurated then
probably i don't know if the day before
or after we will see the impeachment
trial mitch mcconnell is apparently
telling republicans to vote their
conscience
we'll see if that actually becomes
something but i got this map we were
looking at this map of dc and there's a
green
zone where they've like just barricaded
everything off this is really really
crazy some people have pointed out
there's a retired general saying there
hasn't been this much security for
inauguration
since abraham lincoln so a lot of talk
about on all this
and we might actually talk about some
cultural science stuff just kind of get
away from the politics but we'll see how
it plays out
we got a really awesome guest today
joining us is jason rantz hello
i'm a talk radio show host that probably
no one has heard of unless you watch
fox news because then you probably have
seen me uh doing some things
uh on tucker carlson loves you i hear
antiva huge fans
they absolutely adore me and i adore
them as well but lots of content
you're based out of the pacific
northwest yes i i actually live in
seattle i don't just say
i'm uh like a seattle talk show host i
actually live
in the heart of seattle brave ah yeah so
you got to experience the uh crossing
the border into the heart of the
the newly uh born country yeah of chaz
they took away my passport and i had to
sneak in
now the good news is kovid the one
positive in wearing the masks
everywhere is it's kind of hard to
recognize people
however i quickly learned it doesn't
work when you have very distinctive
eyebrows
and they spotted me so quickly this
it is so creepy eyebrows as soon as i
got in and this was like sort of or
early on when it was being established
and you know i had gone down there i was
there with the julio rosas
uh from town hall and we were just
taking some video and then i'm checking
twitter and i'm looking at the hashtags
and people are taking photos and they're
saying jason rantz is here look at his
eyebrows
i know and so i've learned now you wear
a hat uh it makes it harder yeah
or sunglass band or something right on
well thanks for hanging out we're gonna
we got a lot to talk about of course we
got luke caskey he's chilling
did you get your passport stamped at
least they literally just took it
oh my gosh it was it was very traumatic
well howdy i'm an independent journalist
and also not just
now a humble t-shirt seller a vendor but
also a hat seller that you can of course
get very humbly on we are change.org
shirts i produce content on the youtube
channel we are change it's great
being here with all you amazing people
but not just here especially the you
guys the incredible audience out there
that's really something
that is absolutely different i have to i
have t-shirts
hey i'm just saying there's some good
people out there ian
you're chilling right i am did they give
you your passport back no
what they they really took your passport
yes
no who took it you realize it's not an
actual country yes
i know i just walked by no but but i
mean like they were
like stopping people they were they were
so um
and i'm like at a certain point i kind
of believe it would happen so like
frisk you and take your stuff is kind of
like what's going on in dc right now
where you did have some people who were
armed and when cars would go through
they definitely would stop folks because
there was concern that
someone might actually just try to drive
through even it was a sort of an
unjustified concern but they weren't
actually asking for papers but they were
asking like what are you doing here
it's like well everyone is talking about
this so people are coming down and
checking it out i live
here want people here yeah or you know
when you were talking about
masks and how everyone has been wearing
masks i realized all those people that
kind of broke into the white house
weren't wearing masks and now they're
really facing the wrath of
yes not having their faces covered that
was the truth
who do you remember who said that the
other it was a congresswoman and i'll
find it at some point oh yeah forgotten
yeah yeah yeah no i don't think it was
there's another one i know
it must have been if it was for millage
because she's my congresswoman i
probably would have remembered that
how dare they not wear a mask that she
wasn't wearing a mask well
it was the people who the writers who
were going in
they also weren't wearing a mask and
apparently that was something that was
a big deal yeah kind of overshadowing
the actual
big deal but i remember i remember
seeing some media reports about this
this is going to be a super spread or
covet event and uh it doesn't look like
i don't know i haven't
you know really followed it up doesn't
look like that was the case at all
you know we'll see but we'll get into
all this stuff don't forget everybody we
got star patch let's hang out pressing
all the buttons corner listening to all
this craziness
and i am pushing buttons right on now
before we get started with today's show
we have a sponsor that i really want to
talk about so special thanks to them
this is
this is actually really cool so we got
we got they reached out to us and
they say they are the first fully
decentralized social network
no corporation open source nobody can
take your subscribers away
all advertising revenue goes directly to
you as a content creator owned
and self-policed by users like you join
the revolution today
join the revolution today they say on
their site
so i actually i get this email full of
all these things they want me to
talk about but then i actually looked at
it because we've talked a lot about big
tech censorship
and i said you know this this deserves
something a little bit better because
check this out
they say how is pocketnet different from
twitter facebook reddit and other
platforms
there is no central authority or
corporation the platform is run by equal
nodes in a blockchain all revenue is
split between node operators and content
creators
node operators stake pocket coin in
order to mint blocks with rewards and
transaction fees
half of rewards rewards in each block go
to content creators
based on ratings their content gathers
from users so i have this
i have this list of things they want me
to talk about and i'll mention some of
it but you know ian and i we
we went back and forth a little bit
actually really impressed with the idea
of a totally decentralized social media
platform
fantastic bill and i have been working
on it at mine since like 2013 is when we
first thought like we got it and we got
this thing called nomad but
i mean it is like bare bones this is
awesome yeah so this is pocketnet.app
and they they mention the future so i i
do want to read for you some of the
things they they you know i should say
only users decide what content is
appropriate for them to see when you get
high ratings for your content or
comments you earn pocket coin
these poc uh pocket net system token uh
the pocketness is a pocketnet system
token
and you increase your reputation more
reputation gives you more prominence to
your content
you can create a private key login at
pocketnet.app
and uh i mean check it out so look we i
started
looking through the things that they
were mentioning and the one and most
important thing for any of these
networks because i
uh i recently got you know hit on
facebook and everyone keeps saying oh go
to this platform go to that platform and
i keep saying
they're centralized if if you go to one
of these even alternative platforms and
they take out the servers everybody's
gone
so when i check when i when i when i got
this uh request for a sponsorship
and i saw that there's no central
authority i'm like that is probably the
legit
most promising idea you know in terms of
a social network because we've
definitely talked about decentralization
and getting the point where you are in
control of your servers your nodes and
your connection
and then no one can ban you so hey
special thanks to pocketnet for
sponsoring the show
you can check out pocketnet in the link
below it's pocketnet.app but again
seriously wow it sounds
really really cool maybe we'll talk
about a little bit later because i'm
actually impressed by this
but don't forget you can go to
timcast.com and become a member we
actually have a members-only post up
right now
with richie mcginnis talking about how
he was defamed by the new york times as
a
right-wing reporter actually they
defamed him as a rioter claiming he
punched the glass
we sat down talked about 10 minutes
after the show yesterday so that's up
right now at timcast.com
check it out thanks for hanging out
smash that subscribe button that like
button
notification bell let's get to the news
all right so here's what we got
this is great from the guardian trump
ally mike lindell of mypillow
pushes martial law at white house
photographer snaps pictures of notes
near west wing visible words include
move cash patel to cia acting
interesting they say donald trump will
be replaced as president in five days
time by joe biden
trump continues to basically claim his
election defeat by the democrat was the
result of fraud
the president has now said he disavows
the violence as we get
lindell has seen has risen to prominence
among allies urging the president on his
attempts to deny reality
on his facebook page on friday the
mustachioed seller of sleep aids wrote
keep the faith everyone we will have our
president donald
trump four more years later a washington
post photographer caught images of
lindell in which parts of notes he
carried were visible
among visible texts were the words quote
insurrection act now as a result
of the assault on v and that's it then
it says
quote martial law if necessary and quote
move kash patel to cia
acting the notes also referred to sidney
powell an attorney and conspiracy
theorist
involved in trump campaign lawsuits
meant to overturn election results in
battleground states
almost all of which have been
unsuccessful now we have the images
right here
so this is tweeted by jabin botsford my
pillow usa ceo mike lindell shows off
his notes before going into the west
wing at the white house
on friday january 15th and you can see
some things
we don't know what this is i'll tell you
right away what my my biggest problem
with this is
for all we know at the top of the page
it says hypothetical or it says
recently you know linwood posted to
parlor the following
and it could just be example text it
could be a reference it could be
fake we don't know what it is or or or
what you know what he's supposedly
talking about why things are you know
there's redacted sentences on this page
the media just took a picture of this
zoomed in and now they're running the
story as though the my pillow guy
is like trying to stay jakku and that's
like the narrative now it's trending on
twitter
so um i guess let's just let's just get
down to it
jason is the my pillow guy staging a
coup i mean very clearly
i will say this so in the context of all
the things that are happening
and some of the crazy things that have
been said by trump loyalists
i understand why there might be the jump
to conclude that these are his thoughts
you are obviously correct in that they
do not have proof he has since come out
i think it was the washington examiner
he spoke to basically saying no these
were notes from a lawyer
now i don't know if that clarifies was
the lawyer
promoting this and you were then handing
it to the president
apparently the president had read it
they met for about five to ten minutes
and that was that
you know i think it's a fair game to
point out the crazy stuff
on that sheet of paper yeah i agree
let's not go ahead and just
automatically assume but let's also not
pretend that mike lindell has not said
some crazy things he he has he has but
can am i allowed to just please live in
the reality where the my pillow guy is
the masterpine
behind this coup to take over you know
and help trump stay proud i thought i
was supporting that
maybe he has a pillow fort you don't
know of course yes
yeah wow how how uh it's it's 2021
things are supposed to chill out
i i like that meme where it's like yay
2020 is over
and six days into 2021 and it's the
viking guy
the senate building or whatever and now
uh it's it's day 15
and they're claiming that my pillow guy
is trying to and tell the president to
invoke the insurrection act
maybe maybe i mean he's tweeted about it
hasn't he hasn't he said
in the past something about martial law
i don't remember if it was martial law
specifically but he's definitely
sort of flirted certainly there you've
obviously
heard people making this exact same
claim i've seen some of these tweets
from random people
which is very odd if you're saying the
president is not
a dictator to then actually say you
should send
national guard to complete just call
marshall up
i i was right work i was reading about
world war ii man because we had a
comment the other day about the beer
hall push
is that i pronounce it i'm not entirely
sure where uh in 1923 the nazis tried
staging a coup and got stopped and so
i've been reading a decent amount about
uh history i was reading about italy i
was reading about the soviet union in
germany
and i'm just imagining like if in a
hundred years some kid is like studying
history and it's like in 2021 the ceo of
a pillow company
had met with the president and like you
know like that's the catalyst for this
i'm reading about world war ii and it's
like they say you know hitler went in
they surrounded the beer hall he jumps
up on a chair and he fires a gun in the
air and everyone stops and he yells it's
the revolution and it's this very
dramatic reading of history about like
what happened at this time
now he failed of course he went to
prison for a short period of time
and then it was only like 10 years later
he ended up getting elected am i
supposed to believe that history will
look back on this time
and this is what like the future
generations are gonna are gonna hear
about
like we hear these really dramatic
stories these famous quotes i mean think
about these famous quotes like give me
liberty or give me death
i would rather die on my feet than live
on my knees we're gonna have in a
hundred years
the ceo of the pillow company said
invoke the insurrection act because
you know cults and whatever
the quote's gonna be i'm taking uh many
calls and many meetings all day
i mean think about it that's kind of
incredible how we got to this point
is it how is it you know what i wonder
this
is it possible that back in the day when
when these these past statesmen and
and you know politicians when they were
saying these quotes the average person
just rolled their eyes and was like
not that impressed by them you know what
i mean yeah i just listened to
herbert hoover i think it was the
president uh 1928 he basically served us
the great depression
um man he was dry and boring to listen
to
really boring i'd rather have the pillow
guy definitely yeah
so uh i'm looking at the news right now
from the white house uh correspondent
uh for the washington post and he says
quote talked to mike lindell this
evening he said
lawyer gave him notes to share with
potus but
repeatedly wouldn't say what lawyer he
said he met with trump for
five to ten minutes and then he referred
to council's office
said the lawyers were disinterested very
disinterested
and that he allegedly shared this
document with this washington
post guy um and um he goes on from there
so it doesn't say it doesn't say who the
lawyer was yeah he doesn't want to say
who the lawyer was if it was lynn wood
would you believe that
it kind of depends that's amazing
you know because we have no conclusive
evidence i'm going to choose to live in
the world where the pillow guy is
colluding with trump to
you know love it no it's it's not going
to happen i mean
it really is strange how we've come to
this point where people every day seem
to think there's going to be some kind
of big
move by trump and it never happens
you know i i look to some of the most
prominent and vocal trump supporters
over the past several years people like
scott adams and cernovich and they're
they're talking down they're like well
you know it's time to move on it
happened it's
you know what are we gonna do time for
trump to leave and things like that
and i still see people i still see posts
on facebook where they're like
tomorrow's the day donald trump's gonna
invoke
and i'm like you said that last week man
and nothing happened
why why is this why are there so many
people on the left who are convinced
that the nazis have taken over there was
one journalist who tweeted literal nazis
stormed the capital and i'm like dude
the life magic shaman who thinks is an
alien i don't think he's a nazi man i
think he's just unwell
you know why i think it is because
they've been dosing kids with aspartame
since the 80s and they're a bunch of
grown kids
thinking that they're still watching
cartoons and they're expecting like a
fantasy ending
too i don't know i don't i don't know
about all that but people
just don't want to live in reality man
no and you know let's be honest about
the social media aspect of it
i mean we tend to amplify the crazy
that's what social media does and that's
why some of us are on it right because
we
are fascinated by the lunacy and that's
all that this
is now does it strike me as a little bit
more ludacy than
at least i expected yes because even you
know on my radio show as i
talk about what happened and i call it a
riot and i say the president was wrong
i didn't think it was impeachable but i
did say he has some responsibility here
immediately you just get immediately
attacked that you're not allowed to
criticize trump at all and
as much as i don't like the whole cult
of personality
narrative and talking point that has
been used this was the first time at
least
i've noticed it just outwardly absurd
yeah it just went too far and you know
it's good to be
loyal it's not good to be blindly loyal
i think i think many of us you know
because we
i i've done so many segments defending
the president
i think it was uh dave smith comedian
who pointed out
that you want to criticize him but the
critics of trump are so
insane yeah you're forced to look in the
other direction and say no no like
you know that they'll claim you know
donald trump could walk past a dog and
smile and they'll claim that he tried to
kick it or something
or like the fish thing with shinzo abe
where he he poured the food into the
pond because shinzo abe did
but they zoom in and make it seem like
he did something wrong so instead of
being able to be like
trump should do this better the media is
doing worse
you know now i think what's happening is
we're at this point where
most people most of them uh especially
those who had been defending the
president recognize
he's out and joe biden is about to come
in but there are some people who are
used to hearing the defense of trump who
liked it
who have kept going they've never
stopped so for you know people like us
you know you mention on your show you
criticize or you know say things like
like it's over
we we put the brakes on and we're like
well as far as this train goes and they
just went
off the tracks and they keep going
that's why it's crazy when you when you
see lynn wood
getting as many retweets as he was
getting like that's that's
he was getting like 20 000 retweets when
he would say things like mike pence is a
traitor and the firing squads
like what are you talking about you know
what i mean like where's this coming
from
i tell myself it's a lot of people
retweeting and saying this is insane
because i don't want to believe no no
but these are not quote tweets
like you you can quote tweet and say
this guy's nuts because i did
and then i had a lot of people respond
and say i don't know we'll see how it
plays out and i'm like
sure i guess but come on man we don't
what could possibly happen
seriously what could possibly happen i i
god bless the imaginations of a lot of
people
and it pains me to say that because look
i'm a republican i'm a conservative
i supported trump i was critical when he
deserved to be criticized but i
sort of had the same position of the
other side has gone
so over the top in criticizing
everything
my natural tendency was to defend right
even in
instances where i wouldn't normally give
that kind of lever
or leeway to to a politician because of
how over the top the other side was
it's just it's a little bit too much it
becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy because we've been told by the
left for the last
four and a half years a riot like what
happened or the siege
was going to happen we were told that
and every time they said that in the
past we're like there's been no violence
everyone relaxed
meanwhile there was actual violence on
the left in which they completely
ignored it
and then the time it does actually
happen and i'm not downplaying it it was
incredibly
serious symbolically way more damaging
to this nation
i think than six or seven months of blm
riots or antiva riots because of
just what it stands for but y'all didn't
say anything then
they defended it kamala harris raised
money for them it's
it really is absurd and it just feeds in
to this culture this environment
that's allowing for this to continue i i
don't think this is going to stop
because of how people are reacting
jason you made a good point before
saying how people are fascinated by
what's on social media i would even go
further and say that they're captivated
by it
and because of the echo chambers because
of the censorship efforts i would say
that's one of the ingredients that cause
that is causing some of the madness that
we're experiencing right now because
if people were able to talk through
we're able to communicate
honestly without any sensors without
being put into the dark corners of the
internet
i think things would be a lot calmer and
i think now with everything happening
it's only going to get worse because
those same ingredients are only added on
instead of being reduced
to this crap pie that's in front of all
of us the the
real money right now in political
commentary the left
absolutely if if you know if if i if i
was the griffith they claimed i was
i'd be 100 on board for biden and all
this democrat stuff and i'll tell you
what the beanie would be pink
well here yes it would have little
little ears yes no here's here's the
reason though
um if you if you say things like
what lynn wood is saying oh you're
banned in two seconds
if you say there was fraud or anything
like that they smear you they defame you
they take away your ads they boot you
from sponsors and they ban you outright
but if i were to do a show where i
claimed trump
is a fascist dictator this proves it
the lindell meeting proves there's an
aku attempt and we almost stay vigilant
and that it's russia and we know it well
they'll promote it
so it's enjoy reading they'll they will
boost it yeah right right rachel maddow
so that's the imbalance there is money
to be made
by pushing the leftist narrative even
when it's unhinged but on the right
you're banned in two seconds
but how does that change so you have
trump out of office
you've got biden in there let's do the
first 100 days will be oh how refreshing
it is
we now have a real president there and
they'll fluff everything up
i have then what i have a feeling on
this show we're going to be like day two
joe biden has bombed 17 kids again and
then the media is going to be like
if we could even find out about it
because of all the sensors
of all the legitimate news uh
organizations that actually do
talk about american foreign policy if if
you under if if you remember
during the presidential debates this
wasn't even a topic of
debate this wasn't even a topic of
discussion well they can't waste the
second one yes
so we might not even know what's
happening outside because of all the
communications lines being controlled
and being censored
but what i think is going to happen is
going to be very fascinating because
these organizations these groups these
larger ideologies are predicated
on attacking on going after and being
offensive instead of defensive so i
truly do believe that after the first
hundred days after trump
they're gonna start eating their own
they're gonna start attacking each other
tearing each other to shreds
because all that's left is is them and
they're going to find some kind of micro
microaggression they're going to find
some kind of privilege they're going to
find
something to to eat each other apart
because there's no one else to hit well
so they're already starting to go after
fox and so
my assumption is they're going to
continue to do that oh yeah but you're
right i think
at some point so cnn brands themselves
now they're just the anti-trump
network that's what they do which is
what msnbc is supposed to do and msnbc
is at least honest
about their brand this is they're
leaning forward and cnn was lying
but now they're in direct competition
with a democratic
house senate and white house so
they're going to have to go after each
other you can go after
fox all you want it's not going to work
but i hear they want that
you know it was at t on cnn now they
want to sell jim acosta
we'll just we'll just we'll just say
reassigned i won't say fired
uh what else is going on they canceled
the airport uh cnn airport is is gone as
of march
i think they realize that the only thing
that kept them floating was donald trump
yeah it was truly a glorious past four
years of unhinged
desperation screaming at the top of
their lungs about trump nonstop
that's the damage you open up cnn you
turn on cnn it's just everyone's
screaming and
trump without him i think they're gonna
try the trumpism
angle trump-ism oh the problem is
they've already banned all these people
twitter purged the q anon people what
are they going to complain about so i
think you're right luke
they're going to start looking so here's
what happens they get rid of the right
what's left
moderates when the moderates are gone
liberals
and then there's going to be eating each
other like it's auroboros and then
from my kind of understanding i do see
elements of the far left getting
attacked first
because they're the most vocal ones but
the the institutional power
is amongst the the corporatists the
sellouts the establishment so
i think right after the moderates it's
definitely going to be the farther left
the kind of
not even i don't i don't want to say aoc
because she's more establishment now
than anything else but anyone kind of
representing these ideas i think it's
going to get the boot
but another interesting factor to really
kind of remember here
is that before donald trump was
president the mainstream media ratings
their viewership was
tanking going down and there's a
legitimate argument to make that donald
trump
saved the mainstream in fact saved cnn
saved all these these national media
organizations that
actually were going out of out of work
because people were saying
i'd rather watch the i'd rather go on
the internet and watch people that look
like me that talk like me that are
actually genuine
and not represented by these bigger
larger interests that just spew talking
points and narratives at me
for their political goal he raised them
as like undead they were dying
i won't let you fully die i like to
imagine jeff zucker at cnn right now
is like you know he's turning the lights
off he's you know
he's like you know pulling on his shirt
straightening his tie and looking at the
studio as everyone leaves and the doors
close
and then he walks up to this giant
golden statue of donald trump tear comes
in his eye he wipes and he goes
thank you thank you you know i think
that
probably won't happen but i was
imagining that the news media probably
would start to go after biden if biden
does something really
stupid because they want to put kamal in
office
so they'll wait until biden pulls the
trigger on too many drone bombs or
the the economy tanks and they can all
put it on biden
i don't think it's going to happen no
not not the drone thing dude they will
never criticize a president for war
yeah they cheered on donald trump he
used to go after bush though
yeah he's a republican they're not gonna
obama how many people
obama killed americans yeah obama
literally was like
uh that's an american blow them up
teenage
american citizens were assassinated by
the doctor well
more than one teenager i was one
teenager um i don't know that exactly i
think i think obama killed
i don't i think it's four americans but
specifically i can name two of them
anwar al-awlaki and abdulrahman
it's a 16 year old american kid who was
he was from i think he was from colorado
colorado he was trying to find out who
his father was and then he went
traveled to yemen and obama ordered a
drone strike on a civilian
uh cafe in a country we're not it's
we're not a war with yemen
and then blew up a civilian restaurant
killing an american citizen
and the media is like oops or i'm sorry
i said the media went to obama and he
went
it was a mistake and they were like good
enough for us pack it in boys we got an
answer
bye everybody and then donald trump
ordered the hit i believe on the sister
and then again
we didn't hear anything about it and
then you know when donald trump becomes
very aggressive with his military the
mainstream media cheers him on
they applaud him they say it's beautiful
it's great he's showing the leadership
so they're not going to do that but
so but i do think you have a good point
ian they'll find something else
as an excuse because they want kamala
they might yeah but i i don't think so
but like two or three years in
i think there's maybe a reason like
maybe now what'll happen is
we have i think marjorie taylor green
says she wants to impeach biden on day
one yeah
maybe they'll go oh no oh he's oh geez
ah i guess we'll have to impeach and
convict bye bye
kamala yay there we go
no right right but i mean i can't
imagine joe biden finishing out his term
for for any reason
because primarily i mean first of all
he's an old guy but but not even just
that they wanted kamala
i i really do think they were trying to
prop up kamala until tulsi gabbard
dropped that nuke and it really really
was damaging and hard to get around
and so then she just disappears then joe
biden all of a sudden becomes the front
runner
and then he picks kamala i don't know we
heard the same exact thing about donald
trump he's not going to last
the four years he didn't even want it
he's definitely not going to run for
reelection
he'll biden will make it the four year
unless there's some you know health
issue that we don't know about he might
he he's almost certainly not going to be
the external president yeah that that
people
might want or maybe they don't want that
why did so many
external being out there being in being
public facing
doing a whole bunch of speeches my sense
is he probably is not going to be that
president
after the first year i think they've
noted the cognitive decline and let's
not be dissing him
he's of age where that happens i think
he's going to be in a wheelchair they're
going to roll him into the sunroom with
a little blanket on his lap and he's
just going to
snore away in the sun well look if that
happens though the whole point of joe
biden was
to get a calming force in the white
house who can then make it easier for a
democrat
the next time around i think it's a bad
strategy if they think it's going to be
kamala harris and i i think you're right
i think they intended it to be
and she did not perform nearly as well
as she was supposed to
let me ask someone why who who is this
political consultant that keeps telling
people like hillary clinton and kamala
harris to laugh inappropriately and
randomly
well and especially if you have the most
irritating and grating laughs
god bless them but you know it really is
there are some people who just have
really unorganic laugh because it's fake
yeah and when it's fake it's really
really grating so just stop it just tell
them to be like normal human being
and you would have thought that they
would have picked that up with hillary
clinton
who came off as presidential if you took
away
all the phony nonsense that killing yeah
i
just i honestly i just don't understand
that it was like you you've got the
worst stereotype type in the world
let's have hillary clinton cackle all
the time yeah
botox in like 2006 she wasn't all
botoxed up and then all of a sudden she
just got all
face jacked and then it started is it
it's it's the equivalent
so because they i think they did it with
sarah palin too which is like
really lean into the small town mayor
thing and use all these
isms and it just it came off as a little
bit too
phony whereas joe biden regardless of
what you think about
his policies as a personality he's
likable
he has a likable personality i don't
trust it but it's a likable person
you're saying you didn't like hillary
clinton who had hot sauce
in her bag when asked about it on a
popular uh hip-hop radio show that
didn't work for you
or kamala harris who somehow managed to
listen to rap before it came out
yeah that was impressive or andrew today
who was at uh an exquisite beautiful
store talking about how he loves the
bodegas who left his bananas behind i
don't know if you've seen that cringy
andrew yang video today
he left his bananas on the table he
bought him and he left him there
he couldn't even peel or peel one and
then he's like yes guys and he was in
the most like amazing
glorious store that you could ever
imagine he's like this is a bodega it
wasn't a buddy what's funny about the
andrew yang running for mayor thing is
that
his big campaign you know policy has
always been universal basic income
and now he's proposing what i think may
be the worst iteration of it
which is it's like uh 500 000
for low-income people in new york which
i'm sorry i know it's cliche but would
just incentivize people
to not work because what happens when
you do things like this is someone could
be on the threshold and say
i better work a couple less hours
otherwise i'll get kicked off these
benefits
if that's i'm giving a a generalization
to what his plan is but more importantly
he's been criticized because you know
theoretically
the plan could work at the federal level
because the fed can print and borrow
money
new york can't new york needs revenue so
where are you going to get this money to
just start giving out to new york
as the rich folks are fleeing right well
they might be bailed out by
biden's new 1.9 trillion dollar plan
that he's putting forward where he talks
about giving
tens of billions of dollars to states
who are who are in need
new york city has been in need before
kovid because of their overspending
now that problem is exacerbated to
20-fold 100-fold because again as you
could as you said
all the people with means are leaving
the people who can't leave are
stuck there and they're literally
talking about changing all the office
buildings into apartment buildings
so who's going to want to live in a
place where there's no jobs
there's nowhere to work and you have the
highest taxes in
nearly all of the united states joe
biden's plan as part of his new 1.9
trillion is an
increase of the min federal minimum wage
to 15 an hour
so across the board everywhere you could
be in the the you know the
uh oklahoma panhandle and make very
little money well good news
fifteen dollars an hour for everybody
yeah all businesses have it i mean they
all have that money just on stamp of
course of course they're just hanging on
to it because they're greedy
right exactly it's uh you know leftists
totally get this
that all businesses everywhere at ever
at any given moment
have millions of dollars just sitting in
a bank account and that
well they're like dragons sitting atop
their pile of gold they just don't want
to give it to anybody
especially in rural america right right
so what we need is a valiant knight
like joe biden to force those dragons to
give up the gold to the town's people
problem solved is this for waiters too
that are making 213 an hour getting
r right they're getting rid of or they
want to get rid of the that
wage tip uh lower minimum wage which
because we did this in seattle and we
had these conversations
i you would be hard-pressed to find a
person who worked
at a restaurant who wanted that idea no
one wanted that they were like we make
so much more money under this current
system and they ended up getting screwed
i'm down for
not having to tip anymore so so that
plan went through and what were the
effects of it
so we're still learning the long-term
effects because this wasn't that long
ago but one thing that we definitely saw
happening was
hours were getting cut because they were
almost hitting that threshold
where they were no longer able to get
subsidies
but if they were to get off those
subsidies because they're now making 15
an hour now it's like 16 and 20
something cents it's still not enough
to live in seattle while at the exact
same time you have the seattle city
council and the mayor's office
constantly changing a whole bunch of
different programs
increasing taxes making it harder to
build homes and apartments
and so the cost of living continues to
go up so
it's it's ludicrous they just ended up
changing the way that uber rideshare uh
the rideshare model so now you have to
guarantee that they're making a
minimum wage on top of all these new
benefits which
uber came out and said okay but as of
right now we're now 25
more expensive to the customers by april
we expect it to be 40
and so far they're sticking it's way
more expensive that's good though
because the cab drivers don't like uber
yeah well that's of course that's really
what this is about but all the drivers
are like oh this is great we're going to
make so much more money
not if people don't take the uber
right and if they do take the uber it's
because they can now afford to take the
uber which means your city
is not appealing to the uh the diverse
diversity of a socioeconomic backgrounds
you're now again catering to people
who can't afford to live in seattle
which is the exact opposite of what you
said you wanted to do
i got to point out the dark truth about
the restaurant industry uh waiters that
make three dollars an hour
will subsist off of cash tips that they
don't
declare and don't pay taxes on the
restaurant also does not have to declare
it or pay taxes on it
that's existed for to be since probably
the beginning of time i love it
if they want to change that and start
forcing them to take salaries
or or huge minimum wages and then no
tips
it's going to destroy the restaurant
industry i know the irs probably doesn't
like to hear that irs but that's the way
the restaurant industry works
they get cash chips they don't decline i
don't think it'll destroy the restaurant
industry but i do think
all current wait staff will get a very
large red pill shove down their throat
when they're like
my income just dropped by 60 something
percent
and the restaurant will have to fire
them because they can't front that money
they're they're it's tip money that
they're they don't have to pay they'll
increase the prices
yeah and then the way people won't come
in and then they won't be able to pay
enough waiters then not to cut back on
their waiters and they want enough
servers to serve the food their service
will decline
people will stop coming in it's just a
downward spot it's kind of funny how the
politicians who promise
to help the poor people the most are
actually creating the most amount of
poor people and
serving and catering the super rich have
you uh uh i think i think you've seen
this video luke but there's a viral
video
there's a video game it's called i
forgot it's called city state 2 maybe
and so there's this guy he plays the
games he makes youtube videos of his
games and then he publishes them
well it was a really funny moment where
he decided to create a city-state
that had no laws and he was like it's
going to be chaos it's going to be
murder and poverty
and so he was like no regulations free
market everything no taxes no support no
police
and then as he progresses through the
game there's zero poverty
every building is becoming a luxury high
rise and he's laughing he's like what's
happening everybody's rich there's no
protest there's no poverty there's no
crime why is this
and then a bunch of libertarians and
handcaps and conservatives started
sharing the video and they were like
progressive tries making an uh
anarcho-capitalist dystopia turns into a
utopia
so i'm not saying the video game is a
perfect model for the real world
but i do think it is important to point
out sometimes
actually kind of a lot of the time the
government tries to step in
thinking they're smart enough as a
committee to alter the economy of an
entire
city of millions of people and that it's
going to work
i'm sorry man look i'm not a large fair
capitalist by any means i'm actually
kind of left on economic policy but i
can i can be the first to tell you a
decentralized network is going to be
smarter
and better at solving problems than a
committee than
a small group of people who can't see
the entire problem for what it is
well especially when you're in these
cities where it's kind of
one party rule i mean and that's the
same for conservatives i imagine
that if you had a large urban city
and it was only run by conservatives
you're running into the same
problems i do think you need the person
to tell you why they think you're wrong
even if you ignore them the entire time
it does start getting into your head
and you do start to question some of
your own moves and i do think that that
ultimately
leads to better decisions but we've got
so many cities
from new york and seattle and portland
and minneapolis
where that just does not exist and we've
seen
the consequences of city halls run that
way
i mean they're just unaccountable
one-party rule
districts that of course we have to
understand are laying the blueprints of
what
most likely will happen on a federal
level
with of course the the federal
government when we're talking about
democrats control of the senate
the the the congress the executive
office
we're seeing something that really is
going to truly shape the future of this
country
and now biden's going to be bailing out
all the horrible mistakes all the
horrible decisions that they made
so what there's no incentive for them to
actually face reality and the
consequences of their horrible actions
because biden's just gonna come in and
bail everyone out on
and who's gonna pay for that the people
who didn't make the bad mistakes the
people
who conserve their money save their
money are now going to have to pay more
taxes and deal with more bull crap
because of other people's mistakes
i'm going to say the naughty words civil
war
and the reason why is what we're seeing
right now appears to be
a political civil war every four years
and it's been increasingly getting worse
2016 was insane trump wins they scream
russia the top of their lungs banging
their heads on the wall
rachel maddow is you know screaming
chris hayes
so jonathan chait goes on msnbc and says
trump may have been an asset of the
russians
since the 80s when they were part of the
soviet union it's just psychotic
nonsense
impeachment impeachment investigations
for years
every see what happens is they use every
political maneuver and every legal
maneuver they have to try and destroy
the other side now what's happening we
got marjory taylor green on day one she
will
she will file articles of impeachment
against joe biden the democrats are now
taking control of
the federal government in terms of the
senate and the house the senate the
house and the executive branch
and then they're going to enact laws
that large portions of the country
does not want the divide between the
cultures of how people
live are so dramatically different that
when you get
uh you know democrats in office it's
they're gonna what
these policies joe biden is proposing
especially gun control for instance
it makes no sense to raise the minimum
wage in rural oklahoma
and ban them from buying guns when they
live in the middle of nowhere why should
the law for new york city be the same as
this place it doesn't make sense that's
why the system we have
but it now that everything's becoming
like hyper federalized
what do we get republicans have to win
the federal level democrats have to at
the federal level
and we get to the point where both sides
continually increase the rhetoric
against the other as they become more
and more different
and more and more opposed to each
other's world view than
hatred fear and eventually violence
so which brings me to this next story
business insider says
according to business insider tucker
carlson mocks alexandria ocasio-cortez
for thinking she might die
during the capital riot in which five
people died you see how they do that
headline
look i i i can't speak to as you know to
what
ocasio-cortez is feeling or fearing but
we also have this story out from nbc
where they said
some democrats think their colleagues
want to kill them
or will kill them or whatever aoc said
she narrowly escaped with her life or
narrowly avoided death
she said that she wasn't sure if she
should go into the secure chamber
because these
her colleagues may reveal her location
to the far right and white supremacists
and she literally calls
members of congress far right white
supremacists
white supremacist sympathizers and that
is insane
they're not they're just republicans but
that kind of rhetoric of the other being
an evil
villain where they view them not as just
a conservative
but as literally a white supremacist and
then saying she thinks she will die
is some of the most extreme rhetoric
i've ever heard in my life why are they
throwing around the racial supremacy
stuff
because it's it's a tribal signal like
you know you know
it's literally the coded language that
the left has said the right uses
non-stop
except there and some folks on the right
use code language
but they're very clearly using
not even close to subtle language here
they're flatly calling someone
a white supremacist and i take you know
as a jew
if you tell me someone is a nazi i'm
going to have a slightly different
response than the average person and so
when you call someone a white
supremacist
i would argue especially because it's
being done in bad faith
you are trying to incite violence it's
not merely trying to demonize the other
side for political game which is clearly
their intent
i just don't think they're thinking it
all the way through
you know there's a the the right many on
the right will call the left
communists or you know far left or
whatever socialists
and then i see a lot of comments from
actual leftists where they're like
you know conservatives call joe biden
far left and that's absurd and i'm like
that that absolutely is absurd
joe biden is establishment corporatist
crony he's not far left
but there's a big difference between
saying ocasio-cortez is a socialist
because she is and her saying they're
white supremacists one of those
is maybe hyperbolic one of those is
extreme bad faith meant to manipulate
and lie
so i was thinking about this i keep
hearing about the double standard
i've reported on the double standard the
media will say
the peaceful protests the media will
stand in front of a burning building and
say
it's it's i i doesn't i know i know
about the fire
but it's mostly peaceful right and then
you get
one event with trump supporters i'm not
talking about the capital and they'll
say
violent extremists and terrorists and
they'll amp it up to him you know
you know tenfold and i was thinking
about this
there's no point in acting like we
should be shocked by this
it was uh aris racino so i'm probably
pronouncing your name wrong i always say
that
he wrote for unheard that conservatives
should stop
whining about this there's no debate
anymore the left
does not care you've got two sides that
want their riders to be protected
and want the other riders to be arrested
right
but i do think it's fair to point out
conservatives are on
the on the losing end of this because
for too long they didn't realize the
game the left was playing
democrats and leftists say say this
exact same thing of republicans
but republicans keep taking democrats at
their word
every step of the way democrats don't
they'll come out and say
these riots are the voice it's the
language of the unheard
and that you have to understand their
anger and then if any trump supporters
come out and just stand on the cap
on the steps of the capitol building in
michigan they screamed terrorist
you're a terrorist when when you have
far leftist marching
you actually get conservatives defending
their right to free speech saying well
you know they have the right to speak
and then when they smash windows and
burn buildings down conservatives
complain and the left says
nothing so i was wondering myself at
what point
will conservatives have to realize the
left isn't playing
by any rules it's just manipulation of
those who are unwilling to learn
or have no idea what's going on i think
actually conservatives realized this a
while ago without one
you know voting for donald trump which
which brings me back to
you're saying voters not politicians
yeah like the like the voters realized
what was going on and said give me trump
and so i there was a comment we got a
super chat a while ago where they said
that when you have two factions and one
is willing to use force to take what
they want and the other isn't
well then you just you'll have a
conflict but when both sides
when the other side decides they're
going to start fighting back then you
have a war
well that's where we are now right it's
not it's not i'm not saying hot war in
the sense of like literal like people
marching
battle on a battlefront i mean you have
democrats
who have been by any means necessary
trying to take power
they literally say those words and
republicans kept acting like
there was a fair game here so the
example is universal condemnation
conservatives and democrat republicans
and democrats conservatives and liberals
about over the capital riots black lives
matter
only conservatives there's clearly
someone not here playing the game
and so as long as conservatives keep
assuming that there's an actual game to
be played they'll keep losing
i i think there's a calculation from
republicans
that will be by allowing it to go on
the voters will get sick of it and
connect the dots
on their own or by pointing it out
they'll connect the dots and get sick of
it and vote these people out
and i think the instincts there are
correct i think what was not calculated
was
the trump effect because trump is very
disruptive
to the traditional way we have
our leaders how they act he was
by being so open on twitter for example
and i i say this about him
all the time where he is the most
transparent president we've ever had
because he just tweets his thoughts but
that makes him very vulnerable
that makes it very easy to go after him
it makes it very easy to say he is too
disruptive and then you've got someone
like a joe biden because remember
when you had all the democrats coming
out there were a whole bunch of people
who were very very very far to the left
and joe biden joe biden was the one who
came out
because i think people instinctively
understood
that they didn't want to go very very
very far because they did that once with
trump from a personality perspective and
it didn't turn out so well
in their view they wanted to calm things
down and so i do
think and we'll find this out in two
years
did is that the was it trump that got in
the way
of a republican strategy to sort of sit
back point out all
of the biases point out the double
standards point out how crazy they are
and just let them hurt themselves i
think he did because he would get on
twitter and be like
the far leftists are something something
galvanizing this group of people and
turning them into this
faction and he was the president and he
would
say that there was a far left movement
and there wasn't but then he helped
create one
there's definitely a far left movement i
think he's got in the way
he wasn't organized until he started
talking not true that's
giving them something to all hate bro
you just didn't see it it's been going
on for a long
long time well i was on the ground at
occupy walking i watched what these
people were doing and it was even before
occupying i was at occupy i wasn't a far
left
extremist and you weren't paying
attention to the facilities down with
the federal reserve
no no no absolutely not bro facilitators
who took over
were intersectional i saw that dude i
was told i couldn't speak because i was
white
exactly they took it over i watched this
all happen that was
years before trump that was five years
trump is not the cause of
trump didn't turn people into this he
was he's a symptom
of what's happening he just galvanized
it i don't think so
i think he's a manifestation of the
anger people were experiencing
and that's why he's an imperfect avatar
he was just the guy who was there
that people put their anger into the
system was broken
their jobs were shipped away free trade
took these things from them
and they saw the game wasn't being
played fairly yes for the people who
voted for him
and the one thing that we all have to
remember is he did not win the popular
vote
which i do think puts a little bit of a
wrinkle in that argument because he won
based on the electoral college vote
and he i mean narrowly and it was a
smart strategy the way that he did it
and he definitely connected with those
voters who felt exactly that way
but when we go from a popular vote
perspective we can't simply ignore that
part for
that explanation and that's why i still
think
you throw him out it was an anomaly
election it was he is an anomaly
candidate
which is why he didn't win a second time
i don't necessarily blame the pandemic
uh obviously it did not help i do think
that when you have four years of the
media that goes after the guy
on everything that he does it does wear
on people and i see 74 million votes the
most of any sitting president
i think the contributing factor was the
media was screaming you turned on any
news outlet
except for fox news i guess and just
imagine brian stopped her going
the whole time and so finally people are
like make it stop make it stop
and then you got regular people who
didn't care were forced into the
political world because of the coveted
lockdowns
they couldn't go out they couldn't
socialize i know i know some people
who have no business being in politics
they only tweet about it now and i'm
like dude
you're you're you're a mechanic you've
never talked this before in your life
and all of a sudden you're like the
democrat cheerleader when the lockdowns
happen
their normal communication was disrupted
the normal things they cared about the
video games the movies the sports
so they go on social media where it's
all politics all the time and then you
force
people into this room where everyone's
just screaming
and then they beg it to stop and they
vote for joe biden
yeah look i 100 agree with people wanted
a reset to calm things down
i think trump would have won uh if there
was no covet
if that didn't happen obviously trump
would have won because we we had moody's
analytics
numerous polls forecasters predicting a
trump victory off of standard metrics
when covet hit a few of them still
predicted the trump victory but many of
them backed away because the economy was
in the gutter
and as they say it's the economy stupid
but i think the biggest factor was
and it's partly uh i think well i should
say partly in many ways trump's fault
trump really went after the media he
made it very personal for them yeah and
he played to their egos
and weaponized that and that turned them
against him to an extreme degree he did
that to people
just common people too well because
trump was like the media it's lying it's
fake news
and he was constantly digging into them
and going after them
they decided to make the fight personal
and so jon stewart brought it up
he said trump played you know these
journalists are very egotistical
so when trump called you know says
something they take it personally and go
after i've honestly never seen a
president be so
antagonistic since nixon nixon was hated
the hippies and the black panther
movement so bad and they did impeach
nixon
you could argue that obama was
antagonistic to the right he criticized
he was he was saying a lot of similar
things about fox news it was in a
different
way right yeah you're writing he wasn't
overtly like on twitter being like those
far
right there was no twitter oh yeah there
was twitter with
uh at the time when obama came in
twitter was
not prominent at all but he wasn't using
his influences to like talk about the
far
right this is the first president to use
twitter
throughout an entire term and even
though i think it's probably the wrong
way to use it
we don't really know if it was the wrong
way or not because he's the first person
to do it no i think i think
there's uh i've talked to a lot of
people throughout the past several years
and most of the regular people i've
spoken to would say you know
the ones that supported him yeah you
know i voted for him but i just wish he
wouldn't tweet
yeah and then he would and people would
roll their eyes
and that was it he gave he gave so much
fuel
to the media to complain about i mean
there were people journalists whose job
was to wait for their phone to buzz with
a trump tweet
people built careers being reply guys to
trump
and that kept the cycle going if trump
just didn't tweet for one month and said
nothing
the news cycle would be forced down
their twitter reply guys would be out of
business
but trump couldn't let it go there's
like a phenomenon where you become
addicted to pain i don't know if you
guys have ever felt like you have like a
sore shoulder and then all of a sudden
one day you change your posture your
is not sore anymore and you miss
tweaking it so you go ahead and you
tweak it again
and the soreness comes back and you're
like oh there's that familiar
have you guys ever done that no no i'm
alone in the room here
so like it has a lot to do with posture
like there's an addiction to
to feeling something whether it's good
or bad
and i think people felt like that with
trump's tweets trump trump would say
something because the media would lie
and then he found his way to speak to
the people directly
so then he would tweet out that's not
true that's fake news
then the people who don't actually care
about trump these like these reply bots
and reply guys
build a career off it what happens is
then they end up getting 700
000 followers building a community
that's
only shared interest is orange man bad
which creates the narrative and keeps it
it fuels
the hatred for trump trump needed to
trump should have done two things
left twitter and went to parlor or mines
or any of these other platforms maybe
pocket net
and then shut up for a little bit he
should have made a youtube channel
he had one he had one well we should
have made daily video vlogs yep that
would
that would be amazing i think he
shouldn't have said anything
no he over communicated yes he did that
was his biggest
issue if you've got someone who is
delivering and this is
a covetous side you're killing it on the
community
in the economy just you're absolutely
killing it from a conservative
perspective you are delivering on
judges you've got foreign policy
decisions that generally are accepted by
folks on the right
people needed a reason to vote against
that yep
and he would give it too often not
always his fault
but he didn't he made it too easy i'm
starting to think that a lot of
politicians a lot of people in the media
are understanding that the more extreme
you could
make a situation the more extreme
language you could use
the more emotional ammunition you have
but they keep forgetting that this leads
to
also extreme actions and they don't
really understand the full kind of
ramifications behind it
and they're caught in this loop trying
to get all the attention trying to get
all the clicks
and i would say you know donald trump
especially with some of his more
bombastic
style was was also a part of that as
much as alexandria ocasio-cortez now i
know people like to label these people
as kind of populists
but also their strongest asset that that
people believe that there that makes
them that makes people believe that
they're populist
i believe is also their achilles heel
which should be understood in context
here as well i was just do you guys see
that
uh picture of kathy griffin holding
trump's head beheaded yeah
i'm not familiar it just started being
recycled kathy griffin this comedian
and but i'll tell you just so if you
don't know look it up kathy griffin
trump's head
uh did a photo shoot where she was like
and she was like in the middle of the
shoot she was like let's just do this
and
held up trump's bloody head as if that's
not incitation to violence like no
spinning things towards what they've
become it's and she didn't get banned
off twitter
she got fired from cnn well she didn't
get banned off twitter and she had a
mental breakdown and was like my life is
over and she was crying and begging for
her job back
she went nuts and then she doubled down
later because her life's already
destroyed but look
think about the level of psychosis on
the left you have to get to before they
actually do anything
she's still on twitter after posting
that like like you were saying
on the right you could say learn to code
gone yeah
like that was really a i mean
it was a free artistic expression i
suppose
to hold the president's head up all the
bloody and beheaded if you want to do it
with biden would that be okay now
well i think someone already tried it
would bite in and was taken down
right yeah i'm not surprised i remember
hearing something
i was surprised it is free expression
and it's also odious
there you go yeah and it can i think it
contributed to like
to this capital riot i think what we
need now
is the next person that needs to leave
office is probably ocasio-cortez
because i think she might be one of the
most high-profile and bombastic
politicians we have i think she's very
very much like trump
i mean you look at the things she says
that we're just talking about where
she's like
i narrowly escaped death my colleagues
are white supremacists who might kill me
it's like dude you're making it all
worse calm down
lauren beaubert is not a white
supremacist she's not going to hurt you
she's just a five foot tall woman who
wants to have a gun people have guns
lots of them calm down yeah but i mean
she she is acting the way that you would
expect
someone that age to act on social media
that
it's all is it lauren the same age is
she uh i think she's a little bit older
actually she's got three points but
still like they're both
you know uh i think you know aoc's in
her early 30s lauren's in her mid-30s
she's a millennial and that's generally
not all millennials
that is generally how millennials act on
social media sure
but this idea that she's somehow you
know against type
she arguably she's going i i don't care
how she acts the issue is
we need everybody to chill out yes and
start talking
and she is setting things on fire and
don't get me wrong
trump did too i think she's very much
like trump okay
now trump's been banned from everything
and they're all cheering for it okay
great if we're gonna be banning people
then she's gotta get banned too because
she says
inflammatory stuff now the left defends
her
and they'll be like that's not true of
course on the right defense trump i
don't care listen
you don't get to act like you are
absolutely perfect
they can come out and say trump's got to
go because he's inflammatory
and simply by saying remember this day
he's inciting violence
okay well then when aoc comes out and
says republicans are white supremacists
who are going to kill me
what do you think is going to happen if
she keeps saying that when she keeps
saying that
what about when she referred to the
immigration centers as concentration
camps and double down
i'm not i'm not gonna say she should be
banned for that okay what i'm saying is
she's allowed to her opinions and i
think she's crazy but when you have
people who are claiming trump is the
problem and she's doing basically
the exact same thing are you gonna call
her out next
no they're not they're gonna defend her
yeah and and a lot of this is the
responsibility of the media
because the truth of the matter is those
of us who are on
twitter uh we are still few and far
between who pay that close attention to
most of this
tucker carlson uh most watched cable
news show in history
is not reaching hundreds of millions of
people right
and so the average person i don't think
is getting this information they are
aware of who she is because she's really
good at building her brand
they probably have an opinion of her but
i bet you if you ask them some
specific questions probably couldn't
answer them about her
and the same i mean we know about donald
trump you go to a college campus we've
all seen the stupid
videos you ask a bunch of questions and
no one knows what they're doing so i
think
that's the average person and so that's
really on the media to sort of step up
and start reporting this more
and it can't just be fox news it can't
just be
one-offs here and there they have to
actually commit to it and they're just
not going to
tucker was the the biggest uh show in
cable
until he came out against sydney powell
or just questioned the evidence
and then his ratings got cut in half and
now fox news is dead last
is that crazy i mean it's not
necessarily a bad thing what happened
was
when fox news challenged sydney powell
tucker carlson was like where's the
evidence and everybody fled
they went to oan and newsmax so there's
some diversification among conservative
news channels
what it really reveals is that while fox
news may have been number one at the
time
in terms of conservative content it was
dead last just because
there was only one channel one channel
means all the conservatives go there
so you got abc nbc cbs msnbc
all these networks and their left
perspective
there's substantially more viewers on
the left perspective than the right
that's been that it's been that way for
for a long time except i think in talk
radio i don't think left has an
equivalent of
anything in talking they tried and they
failed uh many times there's
been i i think because you can get the
content
anywhere else what do you mean the
left leaning and flat out left content
you get everywhere everywhere right
right and so that they did not get
involved in the radio side early enough
they weren't able to really defeat what
conservative talk radio has built now
there's some there there are some
exceptions to that
around the country right inside of the
future yeah not with youtube there yes
exceptions a lot a lot of very big names
doing political commentary and talk on
the left yeah
so i mean actually i think it's a good
thing that if if youtube actually ends
up allowing it the problem is
there are there there are elements on
the left groups like media matters for
instance that will just pump out fake
news
and youtube just says yes so you know uh
we
we had a media matters wrote about us
recently claiming that
because jack murphy who was on the show
said donald trump gave concrete examples
of voter fraud
he didn't say donald trump gave proof he
said examples of
some i believe that's what he said maybe
i'm i'm getting wrong they claimed that
we were pushing this information
and then demanded youtube demonetize the
content
so the the the show is still monetized
but the fact that they're trying to go
after us simply because we're talking
about what trump said
is is a level of depravity you don't see
from the right to the left
the right isn't going after the left and
calling corporations to get them
stripped and removed because they don't
believe in it maybe
yeah they used to the right they
definitely did media is more focused on
the way things look
that their that their listeners or their
viewers uh their viewers
actually learn by watching whereas
conservative
people learn by listening and so that's
why they're drawn to more radio
and you see like rachel maddow with her
her perfect posture and and done up hair
and like
it's all they call him the orange man
like they're talking about the way he
looks
but so it's less about i think that's
interesting
um observation that might be something
to the way people learn
maybe the left tries to claim that talk
radio succeeded on the right because
people on the right are dumb and just
follow the leader
and so you'd get a bill o'reilly or a
conservative personality and then they
would just
you know cluck along following i don't
think that's true i think that's
actually the left the left turns on cnn
and accepts it all as
law as if it's true and then you can see
how the guardian's like
my pillow guy pushes you know martial
law when we don't even know what's on
those papers
like we don't know why it says that for
all we know it says invoking martial law
in the event
and then the part that's missing says
something happens would be really bad
and we should never do that
we don't know what the remainder of that
sentence is all about what it looked
like whereas like james o'keefe it's all
about what you hear
well another element to really kind of
comprehend here is that
when someone is trying to silence people
they don't have the moral high ground
so when you have examples by media
matters we're also seeing other reports
right now
of uh cnn and nbc news new york times
trying to go after
signal and other encrypting messaging
apps when we see alexandria
ocasio-cortez talking about we need to
ban polar we need to put people on list
we need to censor the internet we need
to rein
in the media we're seeing individuals
who are so
scared of ideas of them being challenged
with
just words sounds that they have to
punitively
silence and make sure that those ideas
don't even get discussed or even
thought about they're at such a point in
in their life where they want to control
what you can even think so when you're
coming from that point of view and
you're surrounding yourself with the
the biggest apparatuses of the police
state when
just a couple weeks ago you were totally
apprehensive against the police state
now they're surrounding themselves with
what is it 25 000 armed troops that have
shoot to kill orders
that are transferring washington dc into
a fortress when you have
those kind of larger institutional
powers fomenting themselves
fortifying themselves in you really have
something to to worry about and consider
moving forward that's why i said they're
not playing by any rule set
no they're just like oh the cops are all
bad and then once the cops are resting
trump supporters are like the cops are
our friends well it's a
you really don't want to do violence
against the government i think it's an
example of why because it freaks out the
politicians and then they surround
themselves with 25 000
shoot to kill cops well it depends who's
committing who's committing the violence
who
what political cause is behind the
violence people that storm the capital
that's one example but there's other
examples of entire police departments
being sieged
there's there's other events of of
buildings being lit on fire
people inside of them there was other
events where people got shot and killed
uh during the middle of protest just a
couple weeks ago that
i would say that's political violence
there was political violence the only
problem is it was
called out by the right wingers when it
was happening on the left
but when it's happening on the right
it's called that by right-wingers and
left-wingers rightfully so but it should
always be called out because when you
use
violence politically everyone loses and
you're destroying the dialogue
that could prevent it there are there
are some people who would prefer to live
in a mad max style world
like there some there are some people
that want to watch the world burn
and there are some people that genuinely
believe if i can't have it no one can
and they'd rather burn it all to the
ground than lose the [ __ ] that's crazy i
don't think that's true
that people believe that they don't
sound really people maybe they fantasize
the
i don't think any who would want to just
struggle i'm not saying them the
majority but they exist
it's not about destruction you know
people like that have you have like have
you been reading the news and following
social media well you hear like
like uh you met people what do you call
it like um
hyperbole but i've never met anyone like
that that
if you the way i describe it is when you
open twitter just
picture a guy screaming half of as long
as twitter is you just scroll through
like
there are people on the left and the
right there are people on the right who
are saying
they will not there was a voicemail left
this guy got arrested
leaving a voicemail saying that they
will never allow a democrat to go into
these buildings
and that they would do some really
really bad things i can't repeat
do you know what happens if there's an
actual civil war it is
look at look at aleppo you guys ever see
the photos of before and after in aleppo
it's
down in syria beautiful city after the
war rubble and
death dude if there was a real civil war
they would be targeting
laser targeted drone strikes on houses
like they know where you live
do not go to war with the us government
it's it's not about the u.s not go to
war with the far
left because the u.s government is
backing them a civil war is two factions
fighting over control of one government
or in some definitions factions trying
to leave or split a government
it's not like there's three factions
there's the establishment and the
populist left in the populist right
we don't exactly know what's going to
happen but elements of the military and
elements of law enforcement are being
split among
the left tribe and the right tribe lines
so it's not going to be laser drone
strikes it's going to be
it would literally be military fighting
military or
people just fighting people but i also
think we need to consider when we talk
about this
is the generations of warfare we're not
in that you know look we don't fight
with swords anymore we don't fight with
bows and arrows
i mean i guess you still kind of could
use a compound bow in warfare it's
probably effective in certain guerrilla
war tactics but for the most part war
changes
you know i love that saying from fallout
the video game war never changes it
actually changes a whole lot
the weapons change but the way this
stays we used to hit each other with
fists
then rocks then we we made swords and
clubs
and then we got horses then we got you
know guns then we got missiles and then
we've escalated over and over again and
now we're in propaganda and information
warfare
so the point i'm trying to make is i see
the comments on social media
from people who are saying they would
rather
conflict chaos blown up buildings and
all that if it means
they don't give up and and they and you
know their ideology persists or whatever
but that's why it's so important to push
back non-violently i mean the whole even
talking about civil war makes me
uncomfortable because it does i think
inspire some of the crazies and they do
exist i i
don't i agree like they're not the
largest sum by any means it's probably
less than a half of a percentage point
but they do cause a lot of the problems
and so we have to figure out a way to
address it and i think it is
condemning it well most of the people
calling for it have never really seen
conflict when you look at the a lot of
people who did
see warfare who saw people trying to
kill each other and saw people
die that's the last thing that they want
they're haunted by it they have
ptsd and a lot of these vocal you know
proponents a lot of these most
violent voices or voices that have never
been in combat
don't even know what it is and it needs
to be called out because again
we all lose once that happens well and
stop talking about things as if we're
currently in a war
because we usually hear some of that on
the left and it's coming from
the anti-cop folks who are claiming
we're at war with the police they're
shooting us in the middle of the street
like
no we can have reasonable conversations
about police reform if you'd like but
let's not pretend
that cops are just roaming the streets
of whatever city you're in and they're
just randomly shooting people that's
obviously not happening
so when people talk like that it does
again it's sort of that self-fulfilling
prophecy like i feel like they're
pushing in a direction where we
shouldn't want to go they're not doing
it for that purpose they're doing it to
win
arguments well listen this is my
criticism of aoc
you know we can criticize trump for his
you know bombastic nature
but what aoc is saying right now is
absolutely inflaming everything
i've been saying for the past you know a
couple weeks now we everyone needs to
calm down
meditate go read a book go to nature
stay with your loved ones and even a
month or two before that
stay home make money that was something
mike cernovich said and i agreed with
like now's the time to
for everybody everyone to chill but
there's a reality to this
i i know a lot of people don't like
hearing the phrase civil war
but what would you call it when you have
escalating street battles for several
years
one one group one partisan group using
every legal apparatus at their disposal
to remove the president
ultimately now still trying to and then
it culminates with a year of mass
writing across the country defended by
one
by proponents of one political faction
now you have proponents of one other
political faction
storming the us capitol building so
what you know i think we're absolutely
on that ground
it's certainly conflict we're definitely
not civil war
we're at a cultural war right and there
is a hundred percent there's one
when would it be a civil war a civil war
would be a little bit more
uh engaged with both sides i mean we
should not
pretend that both the right and the left
are doing it at
equal levels as far as you know manpower
for example
and we're not seeing it widespread on
both sides
and i do think that that is a part of
the issue and there's also
there's i don't know if we could say
that there is an ideal
yet that both sides are fighting for
versus a person they're fighting against
i think there's certainly elements
definitely on the left where they've got
ideas that they're fighting for on the
right i
don't know that yet oh they're fighting
against they're fighting against other
ideas potentially but again the fighting
is not really happening
from the right here's the main issue
i'll put it this way as i've often put
it
if this does develop into full into
full-scale hot conflict
then in 50 years they will describe the
moments of january 6 as
well into the civil war meaning we can
go way back
to the berkeley riots where you know
antifa showed up
and were were bashing old trump
supporters throwing explosives at him
so when i saw that stuff i say i usually
say it like this if everything were to
stop
right now and de-escalate people would
say there wasn't a civil war
if it does continue to escalate then we
are absolutely in a civil war right now
one faction just stormed the capital
with the
misguided and rather absurd attempt at
some kind of
shutting down of the of the electoral
vote count process
the people are saying it on on these
videos that are getting released now
more and more videos are coming out
and they're saying things like where's
the count happening you know there's
only one of them
there's it's only one person we can stop
when there's thousands of us one video
where a lady is giving instructions
about where the senate chambers are how
to get there
if you get to the point where you have a
political faction
storming into the capitol building to
subvert
the the political process that's
literally
the borderline definition of what civil
war is if it's inspired by delusion
do you count it as civil yes because
everybody thinks their dictator is right
everybody thinks their leader is the is
the glorious leader
you look at things that would happen you
look at what happened and i'll tell you
the
the main difference the difference
between
the rise of a dictatorship in a civil
war is whether or not one side is armed
and prepared to fight back
so you look at communist china the the
communists just abused and obliterated
and murdered and and destroyed
you look at world war ii germany there
was a lot of fight
fighting between factions in weimar
germany but ultimately
the communist socialists fled because
the legal system
uh at least a certain degree i'm reading
now many of these you know people in
in government really liked them they
they prefer the nazi party over the
communists
if you come now to where we're at now it
could possibly be there won't be a civil
war
because the left controls the cultural
establishment and uh you know
basically the entirety of the federal
government except for the you know
uh supreme court for now if it just goes
that direction
and conservatives just eventually get
steamrolled then no one's going to call
it a civil war
now jason i would agree with you we're
not in you know a civil war a lot of
people use that kind of language
hyperbolically to also get clicks we
have to understand that but
we have to understand uh the future wars
are are fought not with bullets
tanks or guns they're fought with
subversion indoctrination
influence and when we look at the term
fifth generational warfare i think there
is something to consider
about what is happening culturally what
is happening
through social media what is happening
on the mainstream media on hollywood
that is having an effect that in in part
is leading to i believe a larger
conflict
maybe it's a conflict of ideas but those
ideas are paramount when it comes to the
future
of our children the future of this
country and them turning out
to be individuals that are self-harming
self-defeating and and people who you
know
destroy themselves internally through
their bad actions that are promoted
so that's something also to kind of
largely consider here
and if you were a strategic kind of
enemy
what would you rather do would you
rather have a hot war where you have
where there's blood whether it's
gore there's there's so much violence or
would you rather have a war where you
don't even have to shoot a gun
so that's something also worth
considering i have the university of san
diego
uh article from dr wasim ahmad
qureshi fourth and fifth generation
warfare technology and perceptions
and they basically talk about in in
fourth generational warfare it's
it's the blowing of lines between
politics and you know uh
and conflict and civilians so a lot of
people describe what we've been going
through as fourth generational war
because of the low intensity
conflict and violence things like antifa
smashing windows burning things down
spray painting you know
things about liberals but what we're
actually fully entrenched in
is coming off of fourth generational
warfare and moving
heavily into fifth generational warfare
so fifth generational warfare is
manipulation perception
information propaganda etc like luke was
just saying
there was a reason why in the past you
used force against somebody
because you had no other means to gain
control of a region or a group of people
or a resource
today it's extremely easy propaganda and
manipulation that's why tick-tock is so
dangerous
controlled by chinese interests and
influencing our young people
telling them what to think and feel and
what to do and it works
so right now you have online one side
clearly losing in every respect
they're losing physical fights now don't
get me wrong the proud boys
you know have beaten up antifa pretty
badly and some of them got a prison for
it
but if you look at the amount of damage
antifa has done and black lives matter
has done
they've caused massive damage across
this country while symbolically storming
the capital was probably the worst thing
we've seen yet
there's way more institutional and so
and damage to the general public of this
country caused by the left in black
lives matter
so in terms of how much we are seeing
the left push
substantially more 80 20 80 of the of
the pushing in the conflict is coming
from the left
cultural institutions including news
media almost entirely dominated by the
left right now
they frame everything as though the
right is bad the right
being banned left and right and all they
do is beg
their establishment conservative you
know establishing republicans
to re repeal 230 or something which
never happens and won't happen
so ultimately what happens is in my
opinion republican politicians are too
stupid to realize what's happening
around them and thus
they're now having their constituents
purged they will no longer be able to
win a battle of ideas in the fifth
generational conflict
because they sat back and sat on their
hands and did nothing the left was
fighting a fifth generational war while
conservatives were just sitting there
saying like well now let's have a
conversation about it
when you nationalize elections well but
when you look at the house results for
example i mean the democrats were
supposed to win a whole bunch of house
seats and they didn't quite the opposite
and i think that
you know that goes to certainly the
rural
versus urban city divide and it's
definitely a right versus left at that
point but i do think the closer you get
to the people
in most of the country the republicans
tend to do better
when facing the crazy on the left now
when it's both
moderates going or perceived as
moderates going up against each other
then it really is that's local but think
about aoc saying
they're all white supremacists and nazis
and then raising millions of dollars and
getting 12 million followers
lies work and the conservatives aren't
playing on the same battlefield they're
getting wiped out kind of reminds me of
the 60s
like uh nixon had the well lyndon b
johnson had the
the left of the 60s was like the
military-industrial complex
using the media and back then they had
just television and they used it to
manipulate they had project mockingbird
that was like the cia was
paying and extorting these media
companies to pass their lies
and manipulation and the hippies and the
black panthers
were just subverted and they were
totally pressed and beaten down kind of
like you would say the right as being
right now they were organizing but they
couldn't contend with that media
and i just read 40 people died in the
civil rights movement 41 people so it
was
we would never call that a civil war
ever no one's ever even thought to i've
never thought to refer to that era as a
civil war it was just
unrest it was like what we're going
through now i that's what i see
now yeah but i i guess that was
still remnants of the actual civil war
you still had
the democrats for the most part up until
a certain point
being the party of the clan and jim crow
and the racists
so it was almost like it never ended
this is the crazy thing and i just i'm
watching that new movie just came out
have you seen it news of the world
have you heard of it uh i watched about
half of it so far and it's
good you didn't like it well i'm halfway
through and i'm entertained i'm not
gonna pretend it's the greatest movie in
the world but it's interesting because
uh tom hanks he's he plays a former
confederate soldier in texas
and you've got union soldiers in texas
and you can hear the rhetoric from the
the local you know southerners how they
feel about the north
and what really drives their anger and
it's interesting to see this movie
highlight these people are saying rich
northerners trying to force us you know
to tell us how we have to live and what
we have to do obviously civil war was
very much about slavery
but there was a lot a big element of
that's not too dissimilar to what's
happening today
but anyway the reason i bring it up is
in some ways the civil war never ended
you know this is the crazy thing
reconstructed and reconstruction ended
in 1876 when there was this hotly
contested
uh battle over the presidency and
opposing electors
we were sent to dc and they didn't know
what to do so they elected a panel
to just basically negotiate what was
going to happen to avoid the outbreak of
the civil war again
and what they decided basically was to
end reconstruction and they would give
the republican the presidency
from there you ended up with the clan
these elements still existed they still
fought
it made its way into the civil rights
movement and now we have something weird
and different but it's still
the tribes and the cultures are so
dramatically different in these big
cities
in california in new york and chicago
versus in southern
cities and southern states but more
importantly the urban versus rural
divide is extremely profound and
dramatic
and you've got because of the internet
the ideological split becoming more and
more extreme
maybe the reality is there's elements of
what this country went through that
never went away
and it constantly keep getting seated in
some fashion in different ways
or maybe it's just this country is way
too big and people in different states
want to live in different ways
so someone in new york trying to pass a
law on how people in west virginia got
to live that's not going to fly with
people in west virginia
they're like i mean there's a whole
guiding principle behind states rights
but it's being ripped away it is but
that's why we have elections and i i
don't believe that these elections are a
lost cause for republicans i think
in two years we're going to see that
shift and historically we tend to
i think in two years the republicans are
going to be
much more progressive well another thing
to kind of realize here that the base of
the republicans is being wiped out
whether through opioids obesity
self-hate
suicide self-harm the flyover states are
affected by
those things more than a lot of the city
areas and when you look at the the base
they're slowly but surely killing
themselves off in many instances
especially with the high suicide rates
so that's
awesome i kind of like to think they're
actually being strangled out by these
these trade agreements set up by
namely democrats where they took many of
these manufacturing plants and sent them
overseas
trump was one of the reasons why
actually i should stop there and say the
koch brothers and republicans were very
much in favor for a long time as well
i think that's why you get donald trump
because he said to these people in these
in these places where the factories have
been ripped away i'm going to
renegotiate for you
i'm going to fix this problem that's
what people wanted
so i look at a lot of these towns i i
spent a lot of time looking at dying
towns
because i was thinking of like where can
we move and set up a studio with good
internet
that actually has some infrastructure
and it's it's sad to see i read about a
bunch of different cities
in you know in middle america that were
once thriving and the factory got sent
to mexico factory guys into china and
now their population's in rapid decline
people are dying
when people have no purpose is when they
die i was reading there's a documentary
on blue zones
people who live over 100 in like high
numbers and one of the things they
mentioned is that when people
retire it's like the most likely time of
death for a person is it right after
they retire
because they no longer have a purpose
they're not doing anything that they're
wasting away
so what we've seen with covet especially
people sitting at home
they're they're just wasting away
they're getting out of shape their blood
is getting really bad and they're like
you know atrophying
getting depressed a lot of suicides so
you know i don't know long story short
i grew up outside of akron it was a
depressing hell hole uh it was like a
rubber the rubber boom
in the 50s goodyear was founded in akron
and then
after they stopped uh sporting all that
rubber out
the city everyone just moved out so i
grew up in that like
excavated shell of a of a that wasn't a
megalopolis but it was a huge
city in the 50s and man was it
depressing yeah but what we're seeing
right now is
some of those big progressive cities are
starting to
die they're not dying the
quick death that some people are saying
but
they are starting to show signs of that
kind of decay when you look at seattle
and san francisco new york just looking
at the homeless population the opioid
epidemic
it is out of control in the little towns
like cuyahoga falls
where i'm from the opioids are from what
i i'm not there so i don't i'm not
seeing it and i graduated high school
and left the city when
you know in the in the 90s so it hadn't
struck yet it was after we
we invaded afghanistan that we really
started bringing all that poppy in
and making all the heroin for the uh
what are they called oxycodone and stuff
and now the kids are getting pills
off the street or without a prescription
and
apparently it's just so we'll start so
here's my question
for you jason uh why is it that every
single generation in the past hundred
years
has been further left than the previous
uh why do you think my assumption is
they think they have to be because
especially the way that we frame it
right we have to be progressive we have
to move forward and you see
problems okay we haven't evolved enough
and they've been told that the only way
to evolve is to change
your way of thinking not go back but go
forward
and that's the only place that they can
go i do think that there is
but what does forward mean forward means
to them not going back to the way
things might have been and when you're
talking about policies around
homelessness
and crime certainly from a progressive
point of view going back
is not where they want to go because
they say that there are well now you're
uh criminalizing uh poverty and they use
those kinds of terms and i do think that
people are susceptible
to that way of thinking and they feel
bad about it they don't want it
and so they're willing to give a
progressive a shot
at that next great progressive thing
that will cure whatever the city's
problem but why do conservatives
do it why is it that a conservative will
in five years become much more liberal
or progressive i don't know if i believe
that i think it depends on where you're
talking look at donald trump republican
president
uh the 90 of the republican party
supports him and he's the first
president to support gay marriage before
entering office
yes i do think that societally you're
going to have
shifts in opinions and that's always
going to happen
and that i don't necessarily view as a
right versus left issue it was
until it wasn't and when it wasn't it
became a societal shift it was no longer
about politics and that's going to
happen
there are things that conservatives are
looking at that i think
are right on and i think that
progressives might start to make
the move i think you're starting to see
a lot of that in some of the cities when
dealing with crime and homelessness for
example
we may see liberals and democrats become
more in favor of gun rights considering
many of them are now gun owners
especially this year
we're not seeing it yet but it takes
time but when you look at the policies
of what democrats liberals progressives
propose
eventually republicans give in and adopt
those policies
so again sometimes it depends on where
you live
it really does i mean the thing about
donald trump was
and we heard this from the beginning
he's not really a conservative
he identified with the conservatives
because he thought he could win that way
and then of course we have the people
who
voted for him not necessarily because of
his conservative
bona fides right they did it because of
what he stood for they liked what he
stood for
he certainly delivered on some key
conservative
issues and i point to a point although i
don't necessarily think it was him
but it's federal judges being appointed
which has a significant
significant impact on the ways our laws
are interpreted and enforced in this
country
and i think that's how he's going to be
remembered without being
actively remembered that's going to be
his impact and so i think that we have
enough checks and balances to
to stop some of that stuff that sort of
shift
too far to one side now you it can
change you pack the court that does
significantly change things do they have
the votes right now
no they don't appear to have the votes
right now could they in another election
yes which is why a smart republican
party
will really nail down the focus and i
think it's easier to focus on the issues
when you don't have
a candidate or a sitting president
who makes it all about him like an aoc
makes it all about
her right yeah there's some a lot of
people are saying that
whenever a party gains too much power
and starts enacting everything they want
it freaks out moderates and the other
side into action and then they vote and
then we see this you know kind of back
and forth
is the obama shellacking i mean that is
a perfect example of that
you had all this control you had all
this power people didn't want it people
did not want it and even this
time around again slightly different we
consider this a little bit of an anomaly
to
as well because we're in the middle of a
pandemic we decided to shift to
mail-in voting uh which i actually like
i don't like the way that it was done
necessarily but i am a fan of mail-in
voting if you do it correctly and you
set it up
and you actually spend time to make sure
it's secure and can't be beat
i i like that that shifts things around
and republicans need to do a better job
about
changing the uh the way we talk about it
donald trump
killed his candidacy his re-election by
going so hard after
mail-in voting it was such a stupid
strategy
i get why he didn't flip-flopped on it
too he he he flip-flops
too much but on this it hurt him so bad
and it hurt
in georgia as well because when you look
at some of the number it was small the
amount of republicans who decided that
they just were not going to vote or they
were turned off by all this stuff
it was small but it was enough to
deliver the senate to to the democrats
that was winnable so if republicans
maintain control of the senate this
conversation wouldn't happen in the same
way
right some of the themes would come up
so it was one election
one time doesn't necessarily portend
things to come
it could right it absolutely could i'm
just not sure
given the circumstances in which all of
this went down and the people involved
i'm not sure it will again or at least
that's what i tell myself so don't cry
yeah well another thing i want to go
back to what you said about the cities
and and them
failing we also have to understand they
now have institutional support
joe biden is going to be bailing them
out in the billions of dollars
the flyover states the republican states
they don't have a support base they
don't have any kind of institutional
thing that that helps them not be
downtrodden
and i think they're going to be
downtrodden more in the future i i don't
know if i believe that
yet we will see when you look at joe
manchin and how he
supports what he ends up i know he's
kind of all over the place sometimes but
he
just said he's he's a no on two thousand
dollar check so let's see if he
flips and maybe you will you have cinema
uh who
could switch things up too i'm not 100
ready to go there because i
i don't think that they have the votes
yet unless they switch the way that they
have to get the two-thirds majority that
that is completely different and that
does
completely shift things but even then
i'm not even so sure
that they can do that i mean again well
it's politicians
it's in biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
budget i think i was 1.2
did they change that it's 1.9 yeah i
thought 1.92
sorry i cut you off sorry no i would
just say let's see where it goes because
politicians are
political yeah at the end of the day
they look at where they go
and why they take these positions why
don't we ask you guys what you think and
jump over to super chats to see what
people are
talking about make sure you smash that
like button if you want to support the
show
and don't forget to become a member over
at timcast.com we're really trying hard
to get a core base
of members get access to members only
content
get access to private events that we'll
have at our studio venue
and it's because censorship is here the
purge is here
twitter announced what is it 70 000
accounts were banned
so i'm kind of like maybe we should
focus on creating
something different off of these big
tech platforms so again timcast.com
become a member we already have an
exclusive uh segment up with richie
mcginnis the journalist who was defamed
by the new york times
they accused him of being a writer and a
right-wing journalist when they
eventually tried to correct
interesting stuff but let's read some
super chats all right we got
eric douglas says people should read
that hideous strength by c.s lewis
a book even more prophetic than 1984
that deals with the subject of
scientific
authorism interesting david jones says
everyone emailed trump to pardon
julian assange yeah what do you think
about that do you think trump will do it
you think do you think he should
i don't think he's focused on anything
right now other than what's going on
with him and this exit on
uh the 20th yeah honestly like big
military event for himself
i i the report i heard today was he's
literally just leaving
uh on on wednesday morning wednesday
morning
yeah he's just gone well i don't know i
got a random text message from someone
claiming that their brother's niece
you know does that make sense their
brother's niece yeah no that's their kid
their cousin's best friend's niece
said that trump is gonna uh invoke an
executive order and then uh become
super president i my roommate knows him
a little-known uh provision in the
constitution section
43 article 71 about becoming super
president
cool yes it must have been overlooked by
these scholars it's written in magic
marker
yeah sharpie anonymous says
do you think the censorship of social
media is more related to platform
globalization
it's not about the first amendment to
them it's one code one platform
the strictest policy is the rule to save
money they literally said that to me
that's what jack dorsey i got i said
they said our rule base is
a global standard for our global
audience so they're like basically
saying we don't care about you and your
rights
we're just trying to make the lowest
nominator standard to make money around
the world
let's see what is this goku says minds
was given a 24-hour notice by google
so they had to gut their app on the play
store if you would like to join the
exodus from the cartel download the app
from the mind's website is that true did
you do this if that happened the last 48
hours i didn't hear anything
i saw something really i did wait what
yeah
bill bill ottman said something about it
i saw somebody take a screenshot from
mines and post it to twitter wow
yeah because we were promoting them it
happened like two years ago are you sure
it wasn't from that no yes from today i
think
are you positive why don't you check
because that happened a while ago and
bill talked about it
but if they're banning what we're
promoting we really need to promote cnn
and the federal government the most
trusted name and news they're doing
awesome
great job congratulations thank you mr
cooper
great job msnbc also really good yes
awesome
awesome fabulous work do not promote me
[Laughter]
kevin grip says yeah rants there you go
that's correct jonathan galterini says i
love you
not in that way true journalism is alive
and well for people like you have fun
everyone well if you agree with jonathan
timcast.com become a member
we uh uh i'm gonna let everybody in a
secret
in our first members only segment we
swear
a lot good whoa that's kind of a warning
because your kids might be around did
you swear to god
no no we're just swearing it was funny
because in while we're recording richie
swore there's like oh i can't swear i'm
like yes you can
you can you can swear now that's so rich
beauty of getting away from these
sentient stories
i like that more that freedom well i
don't care to swear
you know i did swear because it was
funny it was like that was the joke i
started cussing
um but yeah man you know there's a name
i can't say
on youtube a name of a politically
conscious
consequential individual so nobody say
it if you know the name
we'll get banned instantly someone
watching youtube right now will
turn this stream off if i say two words
yeah yep okay i confirmed it yeah it's
from like today
yeah at the time the screenshot was
taken because it was on mines it was 28
minutes ago it says alert this is from
bill
ottman google play sent mine's a 24-hour
warning our response app was accepted
into the store based on our interim
solution and ninja developers but we had
to remove major functionality from the
version of this app so they did have to
cut their app to keep it in the store
well this weekend yeah we'll reach out
to because we all know bill
and we had them on the show recently
we'll figure out what what's going on
all right let's see gone fall says my
pillow guy used to be a crack addict
didn't think he could make it broke
through the addiction
trump helped him further his career it
makes sense the my pillow guy is
fighting for him
every step i believe it that's it i mean
it's a tremendous story and i got to be
honest
i like the my pillow yeah i kind of did
you so
people either love it or hate it in my
experience i like fantastic yeah
it's i really really like you know what
i think you need a regular pillow and my
pillow and i put the my pillow on top of
the regular pillow
i was at walmart and i saw it and i was
like i'm gonna get one of these because
i see that guy on tv all the time
and it's uh i mean i'll be honest with
you do you need to spend was it 50 bucks
for a pillow i kind of don't think so
but i do like it you know what i mean so
i just got a customized pillow
after filling out a quiz that i'm sure
was just nonsense and i paid an obscene
amount of money for it and i love it
i hate memory foam i hate it so awful i
generally agree it depends on the it's
gotta be it's gonna be a hybrid it can't
just be
memory film are we gonna do a whole
segment dedicated to
hello can we just talk for a moment
and i was one of them i spent an ungodly
amount of money
on a uh one of those pillows from the
brand that we all know
i won't name them and it hurt my neck so
bad memory foam
yes yes me too and i kept it because i
spent 110
on it i knew i knew somebody i knew
somebody who had a memory foam pillow
and i was like oh i'll sleep with this
and i woke up my neck was stiff and i
couldn't remember
so much and i was like i just i just i
would rather sleep on the floor that's
so weird i love memory foam ah
hey i just read a little bit more about
the mind censorship on google it says
that they had to remove
search uh discovery and comments from
the new app
comments comments because probably
because they couldn't police all the
comments
it was too risky but twitter is on the
google app nothing but
my twitter i know yeah i know wow
lots of crazy probably violative stuff
on twitter i don't want to
i don't want to assume you can't even
describe what time facebook is nothing
but comments
facebook is where the the writer is
actually organized
that's nuts man this is this is this
monopolistic bs dude
it's so funny because there are i could
send
was sheryl sandberg i could send her the
links
to all the facebook groups in the
pacific northwest by antifa
and show them the promotion of their
events
and then link them directly to news
stories about the violence
at said event yeah but we didn't do
anything
well google yeah google won't take them
down it's all it's all a big club and
you ain't in it
daniel maxwell says scary thought there
is a faction within our government that
actually wants to start a civil war
believe that they will have control over
military forces allowing them to win
fast and impose a form of government of
their choice on the country
well i want to clarify it's a scary
thought
it's not a fantasy a weird one well i
think
you know there's a lot of silly you know
ideas we entertain sometimes
um but you know like i said there's a
lot of conspiracy theories who think
trump
secretly put the national guard there or
whatever but uh it's not a view i
prescribed to matt m says a peaceful
separation isn't practical because rural
and red
rural red parts and blue states would uh
would want to also break away
and blue states would lose their bread
baskets and have less control of their
food supply
right that's that's why you know when
heaven
sdfu ffs says pocket net sounds like the
old p2p
sharing tech isn't that crazy when we
have like kazaa and like morpheus
oh i love that stuff limewire remember
remember the thing it was like
i think it was because morpheus remember
that
morpheus was a good one but they were
all the same they weren't but the
different interface and right a better
logo morphe is a better
logo what was the first one that
metallica was in limewire no it's before
limewise oh napster
maps yeah yeah but that was just mp3s oh
man those were the days these old
like you downloaded and you could
download anything literally you search
for it somebody had it
that was the one of the greatest places
on the internet they don't do that now
football exists you find anything now
pirate
no no no well maybe but i'm talking like
so there's an
old uh i'll tell you what if you can
find this ladies and gentlemen
then uh i will be eternally grateful so
when i was when i was a kid
my mom got sound blaster for our uh
computer
you know sound blasters sound card sound
blaster and we have the speakers and
we're like yeah
and it came with a demo disc that had
heretic
descent doom
and i can't remember the fourth game how
old did it play like
uh what do you mean like what was the
game like i don't remember
i i only remember the three i remember i
bet someone can figure that out i tried
looking for it was it all in one disc it
was one disc
it was a demo disc from soundblaster
with with a demo of doom heretic and
descent
and there may be i think was one more
game i don't remember your descent was
holding and i looked up
old archives i can't find it back in the
day of kazaa and morpheus
you'd find it in two seconds my body
sold like 20 duel lands for dissent
descent was a fun game so all those
delays are like five bucks each at the
time magic cars are worth like 900
now but if you can find that demo desk
and you know what i'm talking about
i want to find an old copy if it's
freeware at this point
because i just wanna i just you know i
was i just
demo with those games on it and maybe
one more and i couldn't find it
couldn't find it i remember it taking
days to download a movie and i had
friends that were putting conspiracy
videos in mainline hollywood movie
titles
and people are downloading them and then
and then watching conspiracy it looks
like it's
warcraft orcs and humans yeah yeah
dissent
it's the game pack descent destination
saturn doom heretic warcraft orcs and
humans
yeah but you found a copy i'll send it
to you no i don't know no i don't think
that's it
it was a demo disc but i don't know see
what you find monster
you found you found the soundblaster
gamepad cd-rom package of sound blaster
cards 1995.
that's and it has those games on it
descent doom heretic and warcraft
i think that's right let's go all right
let's check how did he find it so
quickly
because he's ian man he's the free the
code guy he's the man of the picture
of the code like neo in the matrix that
is true because
i smoked salvia had something to do with
it
i'd do a whole show on that now we're
talking about it
all right let's see let's see jason
schmidt says with your website breakdown
activities for tickets
i will never go for some skateboarding
activity but you have a gun hunting day
and i will be there
don't really want to join the site and
risk taking and risk taking an activity
from
another from another i guess you got cut
off um
we're not going to be doing
skateboarding events the events that
we're going to do are going to be like
comedy music and political commentary
and it's going to be basically based
around the guests we have on the show
you know so there are a lot of prominent
polit musicians that get into politics i
mean we had uh uh
phil from all that remains on the show
at one point yeah it's things like that
i'm not going to say we've booked
anybody
but we're going to have comedy shows
it'll be political comedy
and you'll come hang out as one of maybe
like 10 people having a drink
and we're gonna broadcast the shows live
but you'll get to be there that's kind
of the plan of being a member
it will be first come first serve so
it'll probably be hard to actually get
considering how many members there are
but you know
fat freddy's cat says dude fix your
website i can't create my username or
something
give me back my ten buckos fat freddy
you gave me five dollars to tell me that
um
so i think what's happening a lot of
people don't realize after you sign up
you get your sign up email and it's
going to people's spam folders
so we're fixing all of this and we're
going to create a splash page and
the site literally went up on monday so
forgive us as we work you know work
through the
the issue uh you should be able to just
re
use your email to request another
password say like you lost your password
but uh we'll we'll figure it out
consider it in beta for the next few
weeks oh it's going to be in beta first
yeah but the thing is look we can't snap
our fingers and create
a massive news enterprise website we
have to start somewhere
so when when we launched we're like it
works everything seems to be working
perfectly
and then once you bring in the users the
bugs start appearing and then we find
them and now we're trying to work them
out to the best of our abilities
so it's pretty beta zachary
says tim lydia ian you have cultivated a
desire to counter the misinfo of the
establishment in me
luke you're an inspiration a very polish
inspiration i'll be creating content in
the coming weeks
very nice
sdfu says from the makers of my pillow
it's my coup d'etat
[Laughter]
pillow man the my pillow guy pillow
fight
yeah let's see amir m says hey tim big
fan since tim cass is expanding
any chance you're hiring potentially
soon we will have some news there's a
lot of stuff going on
but uh for now i think the most
important thing is
there is uncertainty right now with
social media bannings and the purge
and there's serious risk right now to
having a business
primarily be youtube based so this is a
podcast
it does appear on itunes and spotify and
actually does particularly well
relative to other podcasts but youtube
is a way larger portion of traffic
which is why you can tell i'm pushing
timcast.com very heavily
because ideally we can make this
business self-sufficient on an
independent platform that can't be
banned
and you don't need that many people to
do it so look we get
uh i think we get like three all of my
content is getting like three or
no it's probably getting like four
million two million views a day four
million every 48 hours on youtube
metrics
imagine if only 10 000 people actually
watched any of this stuff but they were
all members paying 10 bucks a month
we would never have to worry about
censorship ever again granted we do want
to reach as many people as possible
that's the name of the game i suppose
but we could make this work with a with
with a
with a one percent point one percent of
that audience
if they were just subscribing members
and that's the freedom we really want so
like like i said we did this segment
with richie mcginnis and we were
swearing because it was funny because we
could finally swear
there's a lot of things we can say i can
do a segment after this on the name i
can't say and say it 500 times
it'll be fantastic yes sirius redgamer
says 2024
trump for president and pillow guy vp i
honestly would not would not be
surprised
yeah all right let's see isp ink says
declassified documents available
check live chat for link is that the
obama stuff the obama gate stuff trump
declassified it i don't know if it's out
yet though is it
it was parts of it was at least
declassified today
i did not read it though rob lowe robs
lowe's says tim lydia ian and luke keep
doing what you're doing
you're all awesome thank you for the
great content can't wait to see what
members content has on timcast.com
we're talking about you know luke wants
to set up an airsoft battle
yes between the tim cast iral crew
versus the daily caller crew
the beanie compound crew oh that's what
we're calling
compound crew and then we're thinking of
doing
uh like having you know gopros on
people's heads
live broadcasting remotely oh that
sounds cool all right
live stream you could have luke cam and
like richie cam
and then you're like luke's behind
richie which he doesn't know oh no and
then oh
snipers yeah it'd be cool um we also
have those night vision goggles that can
record hd
yeah we did do a night show yeah night
vision
tyler says tim you should reach out to
bill little and ask him about the after
party and it's mascot it's already on
board
i don't know what that is
fluesboro says hi from sweden tim if you
plan to get a dog please consider
commodore a hungarian guard dog we get
our common door puppy next week directly
from hungary
interesting cool well we were close to
getting a husky
but i just got a german shepherd so
here's an interesting here's an
interesting one mitchell
salazar says i'm in virginia and i saw a
billboard asking people to turn people
in who are at the capitol
wow wow count lugwig ludwig says hey
jason fellow seattleite here
and i seek your advice on how average
citizen can push back against coveted
lockdowns especially in washington
i'm friends with a few restaurateurs and
at least one is terrified she will lose
their eatery
uh she probably will
the the reality of the situation is
washington state is deeply blue and
you're not gonna just
be able to change things now this last
election actually was
way more competitive than a lot of
people thought and there was
no losses of seats on the republican
side where
we kind of thought we were going to lose
some potentially so
that's some that that's that maybe
portends a good future i think you just
got to get more
involved politically i mean washington
in particular is a place that
when you do get involved it actually
does make
a difference on the local level and some
of these races are
being won by just a few hundred votes
sometimes are there instances in
washington of restaurant tours just
staying open yes there are quite a few
and what was it spiffy's
made uh the national rounds uh they now
owe like a hundred fifteen thousand
dollars or something uh in
in fines and they're going through the
court system and they thought that oh we
get in front of a court
in front of a judge they're going to
side with it so far not going
so well but there have been in
washington really across like
ap has a story out this week on
restaurants just saying
no we just can't do it anymore we're not
doing it because we
you know are just trying to be scoff
laws and try to spread covet we're
trying to
help sustain a business and keep our
employees
paid it's just at some point people are
going to just
stop following you're from seattle i am
you ever eat a bag of dicks
dicks is the best i will say
saddle jacks are the best it's a burger
joint it's actually really good
yeah and so the joke is because i think
you mentioned it before every time i
like i lived in seattle very
briefly i lived in fremont and uh i've
been back a couple of times and
everyone's always like what do you want
to do
you want to eat a bag of dicks because
it's a funny thing to ask
and then you actually end up going need
a burger you literally go to dick you go
and get a burger
i know the family so it's uh it's a good
place it's a really good yeah it's
always fun to go to
yeah fat it's it's fast it's kind of
like how mcdonald's the old school
mcdonald's would be you like walk up to
the window and you order and then you
step over and hand you the bag
people on the west coast who know in and
out although right they're just west
coast way better than in and out
i know it's not wait a minute i don't
like in and out i think is overrated
yeah
every swenson's that those make it to
the bigger other side that was like you
sit in your car and you order it they
come out and they take your order and
then they go bring it out to the car i
don't want that that's old school i
don't need the 50s or something
i could i don't like the fact that you
have to walk up just give me a drive
through come on guys
yeah oh you ever watch uh that that
movie the
founder yes how they got rid of the
driver because it was like
who cares he's like sitting down trying
to figure out how to eat and he's just
like just eats in his lap
it was a new thing to them that's
amazing that's a good movie by the way
yeah
better than news of the world yeah black
czar says raising the federal minimum
wage to 15
a corporate power grab a small business
in kansas does not have the same cost of
living terms of silicon valley
they would lay off staff increase prices
or fold
their wealth being redistributed to
walmart amazon etc who can eat the costs
yes absolutely stephen schlack says
i'm in illinois they're stripping cops
of qualified immunity and allowing
unconfirmed reports to stay on their
permanent record
i know a bunch of cops who are getting
out and going to act
and going to act like the fire
department only show when called
well yeah this is a super serious
problem and it's going to get
so much worse in 2021 just in seattle
the official number i think is now 198
from 2020
that is the largest number of officers
to leave the force
we now have the lowest level of
deployable staff since 1993
since which we've grown like 48 or
something in population
it is bad and it's going to get worse
wow
oh this is a really important super chat
from sassypants824
jason's eyebrows are glorious oh she saw
through the mask
thank you let's see uh track media only
says people like aoc
saying what they do that cause this add
how much further they want to go
it causes people to look for hope in
anything they can
daniel henry says conservative
domination of talk radio is simply
because people getting things done can't
watch tv or youtube
they have to listen to work listen and
work at the same time i think so
that's that's true so i i found that a
while ago because i started my channel
making videos like actually going out
and filming stuff and then
intermittently doing commentary videos
because i couldn't travel all the time
and then eventually
just commentary but people would turn my
video on they still do
and then just go about work so they're
hearing it in the background while doing
something else
yeah that sense look radio is is passive
listening
for the most part unless you have what
it's called a p1 which is your
first preference which is the first
person the first station you go to when
you get in the car
obviously as traffic got worse we
capitalized on that and obviously in
some of the other cities where
people aren't actually driving that's
the places where like youtube does best
or
what was that could be that quite quite
did not uh take off
all right let's see brian lane says hey
gang vosh recently said on stream he
would like to come on your show again
after kobet and he planned to have him
on again
love to see varying ideas i'd love to
i'd really love to have him out with
alex jones
that was cool that's what we wanted to
do because uh and it's not about vosh
it's about getting a left and a right
wing personality in the same place
to just have a conversation i guess what
if they wanted to box would you let them
no
i'm not okay what about in the skate
park no no no no no if they want to do a
sanction thing on their own they can go
do that i'm not
that jake paul like boxing it out what's
that called when they agree to fight
mutual combat mutual combat in the
parking lot no
no no none of that's ever going to
happen here they can do that any street
anybody no they cannot it's never going
to happen
all right let's see ann kush narula says
cush says
does ian believe things can get better
if the fed stops dosing the blockchain
with aspartame
i definitely think things can differ i
would say so yeah dosing the blockchain
with aspartame while they free the code
we have more power than we realize
that's something i've learned
over the last 20 years especially with
internet video but i think just in
general our actions have like resounding
effects on our
surroundings gustav anderson says tim
you and your team have been
exceptionally transformational in my
worldview
and how i engage with social political
content literally i've changed my
life thank you all so much for what you
do i appreciate it i think we're just a
group of people that talk about our
feelings
but when you have a when you have a
bunch of people who are constantly
reading the news and have different
views on them then you may
have you have a conversation you know
plus if you're fearless
to tell your friends i say i can't swear
i don't want to swear
when i say that segment yeah if you want
to hear what i really say to tim
check the bonus section it's just
screaming ian's like you
god bro you should listen to us play
magic and just go at each other
says hey i love rants seems like a solid
dude i live in auburn and i helped
support
spd through jason's fundraising efforts
oh awesome
thank you james byrne says yo ian dudes
in man dresses
and outdated weapons have been kicking
america's rear end for 20 years
i have been there and done that tell me
tell me more about that i think he's
talking about the middle east
oh dudes and man dresses i wore a man
dress at burning man that's why i was a
little confused
so what was this what was his point
it's about how like in afghanistan and
vietnam farmers with
like just guns overwhelm the us yeah
yeah what kind of dress did you wear at
burning man it was a skirt that was
offered to me by a friend of mine and i
i i don't have it anymore i'll show you
it's green
true north says i really hope that my
pillow guy and trump start a civil war
just so that a hundred years from now
they can refer to it as the great pillow
fight of 2021.
oh i love it
count ludwig says hey jason fellow
seattle light here and i seek your
advice
oh that's weird oh that got posted twice
i guess
snazzy butterfly says shout out to ian i
grew up in akron too oh holler
there you go you guys are like basically
best friends the water was like well
water it tasted weird though
something about it probably really dirty
i didn't know at the time
jacob diesewski
i'm saying your name i'm trying to
pronounce it he says tim you know right
now certain media is claiming the civil
war
and trump as a confederate president
side note see if luke can pronounce my
last name
how do you say it spell it d-y-c-z
e-w-s-k-i e-w i bet we can
he totally can uh dr drazek
jesek jizek
i didn't write down what you were saying
but i'm just making up words right now
to see if i can get it luke doesn't
really speak polish he just pretends to
i mean and it's actually just gibberish
all right let's see eric a says you
asked the other day
what's next with leftists keep pushing
norms map is next to be pushed remember
salon wrote an article how they're not
monsters crowder's done some good vids
on this
map you know that is minor attracted
persons
i don't is that a pedophile really oh my
god that's what that and that's a big
thing that's been on twitter and people
like left and right have been
calling these people out like crazy it's
creepy stuff these people are disgusting
that's what they're calling themselves
yeah yup
yup oh my gosh yeah this is why i hate
twitter
yeah i mean i don't know the left is
going after them too so are they okay
well you know what
see that's good you usually on the left
no judgments we should be judging these
people
come on yep
let's see artersky says dems watch tv
because they have more time
republicans listen to radio while
working one family guy episode that they
overthrow the government
things started to go sideways had to
create a new government lol great show
and then he says c-z-e-s-c
what is that check chase what does that
mean
wait hi oh hi let's see
mild says just for you i'm researching
the history of the fed to get a grasp on
what the heck is going on dude als uh
also
chance of haram gorilla workout merch i
don't know now we're talking
the official i am a gorilla t-shirt
because i know everyone really loves the
gorilla emoji
go to timcast.com click the shop button
and then you should see the
i am a gorilla t-shirt let me just
remind everybody you see the t-shirts
that we make here for the tim cast irl
podcast are somewhat meaningless
it's a gorilla or it's me with like
harambe i say bubbles
luke's got a whole bag of like crazy
political commentary and humor
well yeah i like to make people think
and and to interact with other people in
the wild of our
environment and uh one great way to have
a conversation
is with a wild t-shirt you know and you
know what would really help start a
conversation
wearing a shirt that says trump just in
big letters and walk around say like in
new york or los angeles
you'll start a conversation real quick
it'll be for dc
videos on youtube a lot of them but it's
he's a hearthstone player
called trump yeah that freaks people out
you know it'll be fun to make
uh a red hat that looks like make
america great again but
is completely meaningless like make
trump go back now
or like make trump jump lawnmower well
i have a red hat that says make taxation
theft again and make orwell fiction
again
but i mean like infuses people a lot
totally gibberish
like make a shirt that says like that
look oh you know
no no no no i think i think i want to
make a shirt that doesn't you can't tell
if it's pro or anti-trump
it just says like donald trump we don't
deserve we don't deserve him
yes that's a michael malus joke by the
way he always he always responds to
he would respond to trump saying like we
don't deserve him and is perfect
it's brilliant because unlike everybody
you don't know who
you don't know what's going on is he
forward against the guy i have no idea
yelled at him either way it's twitter
eric bart thank you for that super chat
thank you lost cause says wait tim
swearing take my money well that's a
super chat you need to go to
teamcast.com become a member
and we got the segment up with richie um
we're probably going to figure out some
better compression for the videos we
upload because
the videos that we put up are like high
quality and we host we host them on our
own and stuff
but we have a bunch of other stuff too i
think we're actually gonna do
limited edition shirts and merch and
stuff and you know we're working on it
i think the goal is i should have done
this from the get-go is making the focus
of the company be
just core users and membership and like
the website
there are a lot of podcasts you've never
heard of that do way better than we do
because that's what they did
and so that's something i realized you
know i'm like wow we should have done
that
we should have done that there are
podcasts that have way less subscribers
and these people are insanely rich
because of it
i want to i want to expand though when i
want to do more so i'm figuring
the appropriate way to protect ourselves
from censorship like many of these
left-wing podcasts do is exactly that
bass player says my last jet before
becoming a member and in regards to
crowder
he takes breaks in summer and winter for
the holidays he'll be back before the
end of the month
okay cool let's see buffalo bill says my
pillow guy got sued for saying it healed
migraine and back
back pain he's a grifter is that true of
the my pillow guy
i never would have thought that
all right let's see here we'll jump down
make sure we get to as many super chats
as possible
nolan harris says i know you you guys
like magic the gathering do you all read
fantasy sci-fi
if so what do you like geez i don't me
and maybe
i was just watching a bunch of lord of
the rings the simarillion i haven't
heard it yet but i was listening to some
old tolkien interview from the 60s
that guy like speaks like a hop i mean
he's like gandalf
yeah so let's see anthony calva says hey
tim can you acknowledge my existence
i'm from jersey too by the way and
murphy sucks i agree
yes here we go uh this one's from zombie
slayer
isaac says nah have vosh on with eric
july
yeah that would be nice yeah that'd be
cool that'd be cool because i think
they're both smart and they have an
interesting conversation
i'm not saying that i completely agree
with vosh though we had quite a
disagreement but
i don't think he's gonna you know i
think it'll be an interesting
conversation bosch is also named ian by
the way
yeah that's cool he'd be good with a lot
of people because he's really smart and
kind of like a socialist like i'm sorry
interrupt you tim
please arthur tenu arthemisia says hey
tim i am a small political youtuber and
worried about the future of my channel
i had a rapid growing audience that
began to dwarf my channel on parlor
what we need are new server companies to
compete with google and amazon
i'm gonna give a shout out to
pocketnet.org again they sponsored the
show we
we i read you know a bit of their thing
early on
and uh at first i you know i get told
like hey
like here's the people who are
interested in sponsoring the show and
then when i looked at their website
and they said there's no company there's
no centralization backing this so no one
can ban you i was like
that's exactly what we need and i'm like
i'm really adamant when it comes to
sponsorships where i'm like i only
literally endorse things i think are
cool so when i read that even before we
started the show me and ian had a little
back and forth where you were like wow
yeah i wonder how many operations how
many pocket coins you need to stake
in order to become one of the miners is
that what it is like you run nodes i
guess
you had to run a node how many pocket
coins you got to stake how much they
cost where to get them
i like the idea so just real quick just
because it just happened like
20 minutes ago virginia officials reach
agreement with secret services shut down
virginia dc bridges tuesday through 6
a.m thursday for inaugural activities
wow i'mma get stuck on on wow
dude creepy man but yeah yeah yeah
anyway so
those that are those that are you know
mentioning decentralized apps and other
options
special thanks to pocketnet.app for
sponsoring the show i i do think it's an
amazing idea
i i gotta stress it because i'm not
trying to just you know keep promoting
them but
we've talked about the fetaverse over
and over again where you have your own
server
so like instead of using twitter to send
messages people just follow you on your
server
is really really an interesting concept
so to see people actually implementing
this
i i i want to see more of this so
let's see ghost crusaders says facebook
and instagram reinstated trump's
accounts
i don't think they ever banned him i
think they they restricted him yeah well
he can't
he can't post his accounts are still
there though
icefox says went to become a member it
took a paypal payment but i can't log in
try forget my password with my paypal
account email the email without the
domain
and the paypal payment id what am i
doing wrong check your spam folder
uh if not email members at timcast.com
and then we'll
get you the proper link and get it
sorted through and uh
let me just let me just tell you guys uh
one of the one of the challenges with
launching the site
is that we immediately got like
thousands of people signing up right
away
and so we're just a small handful of
people
trying our best so we'll we'll we'll get
to as many people as possible
whatever you do you need to i it's
probably pointless to just bring up
again but uh
people are emailing a bunch of the wrong
emails and it's not getting sorted out
properly so just members at timcast.com
if you encounter a problem
check your spam folder and we're gonna
we're gonna set up more to sort through
this and create a splash page and then
create
you know redundancies to make sure
people who encounter any problems can
solve it
preston thames says if someone had told
me that we would go into a near
multi-year lockdown economic crash
a populist winning presidency after
harambe happened i never would have
believed you
oh harambe yeah cat mc26 says can you
make
sock gorillas like the monkey's grandma
made i
i don't i don't know maybe we'll see
what teespring offers
if you have not already make sure you
smash that like button subscribe to the
notification bell
because it really does help and go to
timcast.com become a member we will have
more bonus segments coming up but you
really check out the one we just did
with richie mcginnis of the daily caller
because he was smeared by the new york
times as a rioter they literally made it
up they claimed he punched the glass
never happened meanwhile cnn puts on one
one of the actual
rioters who's a leftist and acts like
he's a journalist
check out that segment at timcast.com
become a member and
thank you all so much for hanging out
for the show jason thank you for coming
the show do you want to mention
social media or sure jason rants on
twitter
r-a-n-t-z i lost so many when i was
critical of trump and then with all the
purging and stuff so i'd like to
boost that back up hey you know what
it's all a part of life just got to keep
you keep grinding you keep working and
you don't worry too much
i'm gonna sign up for your sponsor
though i'm excited as much as i do
yeah i don't like i'm not signing up for
anything else i'm not going to gab
i know people keep telling me to go to i
was there at the beginning
a lot of anti-semitism i am not going
back
i am just out but i will go there i went
to gab a couple days ago man it was slow
yeah i think they just got overloaded
they're getting slammed but dude my
respect they're building infrastructure
so they're trying to ban gab i think the
issues you know but uh
actually i i should i was going to say
something wrong no gab decentralized gab
use the fetter verse now so that was a
while ago they're doing everything in
their power to prevent them from being
taken down it's
it's actually impressive and i
apparently there's rumors about like the
doj is like left to start demanding the
doj investigate them now because
when when the the private sector fails
use the power of the government to shut
down your political opponents right
yeah yeah but uh uh yeah you you have
shirts and stuff they're also
doing the same against signal and
telegram which is very worrying as well
but
yes if you want to support my
independent ventures i am luke
we are change on most social media like
facebook and twitter and instagram and
all those other
controlled places but the best thing you
could do is sign up on my email list on
we are change.org in the top right hand
corner and
i don't just sell shirts i sell bikinis
socks and hats
which you can get also on we are
change.org forward slash store if you
want to support me
because you do thank you guys so much
and if you have problems with
decentralized things like signal and
telegram going forward you could always
use something like wire
or uh the matrix protocol with riot it's
a great
encrypted channel mines although their
app it seems chat's going to be offline
but they're
mine's going to be rolling out some
hardcore message
new messaging upgrades which i don't i
don't think bill has authorized me to
talk about yet but
man it's going to be good um of course
i'm ian crossland
thank you tim luke jason lydia i love
you all uh you guys can follow me
anywhere
um on the internet youtube twitter
facebook minds
uh instagram oh i think instagram's
tracking everything you do now did you
guys see that
you know what can i be honest every time
i get served with an ad on instagram it
knows me so well
it's crazy i buy everything i know
i seriously buy every i bought
toothpaste this morning because of an
instagram ad
i didn't know i wanted it they said i do
now tim and i have the same ad and you
bought it what was that do you remember
oh yeah with a solar torch or whatever
crazy dude yep
i think maybe at once the craziest thing
is they sent me an ad for a head shaver
and how do they know i'm bald i wear a
beanie all the time yeah they figured it
out sometimes special recognition
x-ray vision yeah uh anything else i was
going to say i think that's about it i
love you guys you're going to tell
everybody to follow at our petulants
yeah follow us our bachelor's and share
the video share this video if you like
it
yes do yes and then go to timcast.com i
was going to say too that i did buy
tim's christmas gift off of an instagram
ad because i loved it and it was perfect
for him and i thought it was great and
he loved it
the empanada press or whatever yeah it
makes little dumplings it's really cool
we made cheesy dumplings that's amazing
we've got some behind the scenes my
friends thank you all so much for
hanging out we will have
more bonus content so if you if you like
the show then
again sign up for temcast.com we will be
back monday
right monday this monday at 8pm and uh
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you well then
bye guys
you